Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
14 Monat Huge Subscriptions hier
Ja heute von 2 auf 3 gewesen, stimmt
Ja
Weiß nicht, Zeitumstellung ist so eines der unsinnigsten Dinger überhaupt
Niemand braucht Zeitumstellung
Ich bin eh dafür, soll ich euch mal, meine Meinung dazu ist
Es braucht noch nicht mal jemand Zeitzonen
Zeitzonen ist
Load
Overrated AF Zeitzone
Niemand braucht Zeitzonen
Ich mein ganz im Ernst
Wo wäre das Problem
Wenn einfach überall auf der Welt die gleiche Zeit ist
Es ist doch scheiß egal ob 12 Uhr Nacht ist oder 12 Uhr Tag ist
Man gewöhnt sich doch eh dran
Dann verabredet man sich halt um 17 Uhr
Das ist dann halt keine Ahnung
Jetzt wie morgens 9
Was auch immer
Bei uns ist es ja eigentlich minus 2 jetzt
Plus 2
Braucht doch keiner
Wer braucht Zeitzonen
Genau
Genau Weihnachten ist im Sommer
In Australien
Wo ist das Problem
Zeitzonen machen
Ich hab noch kein wirklich gutes Argument
Pro Zeitzonen gehört
Außer, dass man halt sagen kann
Hey 12 Uhr ist halt immer Mittags
Egal wo man ist aber was
Wo also wozu
Ist doch egal
Ich muss mir halt einfach nur merken wo Mittags ist
Wenn mich das irgendwie interessiert
Und das merke ich mir halt schon mit der Zeit
Dafür hast du überhaupt keine Probleme mehr
Mit irgendwelchen Absprachen
Mit irgendwelchen Zeiten
Du kannst so viel Load und Komplexität weglassen
Wenn es keine Zeitzonen gibt
Dass es das alles viel einfacher macht
Also warum
Noch Zeitzonen ich mein okay
Wir können uns ja nicht mal drauf einigen
Sommer und Winterzeit abzuschaffen
Oder Zeitumstellung abzuschaffen
Da können wir uns garantiert nicht weltweit
Auf einigen Zeitzonen abzuschaffen
Ey da haben die Panik geschoben
Ich war ja live dabei damals
Da war ich 16
Krass viel Panik geschoben
Von Krankenhäusern die nicht mehr funktionieren
Bis Banken die nicht mehr funktionieren
Bis Satelliten die abstürzen
Und im Endeffekt ist halt nichts passiert
Naja du musst doch da eigentlich
Also wenn du eine Zeit hast
Die auf der ganzen Welt gilt
Dann musst du doch gar nichts großartig implementieren
Jetzt mit Zeitzonen
Das ist deutlich komplizierter
Du pickst einfach
Eine Zeit und gut ist
Krankenhäuser laufen immer noch
Hey das ist jetzt kein Witz das ist wirklich so
Ich war ja vor 2-3 Jahren
Mit meiner Mutter mal auf der Notaufnahme
Und das erste was ich gesehen hab
Ist irgendein Herz
Überwachungsgerät
Mit Windows XP
Das erste was ich gesehen hab ist Windows XP gebootet wird
Da hab ich dann auch schon gedacht
MonkaS
Was ist da los?
Aber gut
Das Zeug hängt ja zum Glück nicht im Internet
Hoff ich
Man weiß ja nie
Im Zweifelsfall wahrscheinlich schon
Das könnten wir auch machen
Wir könnten auch Zeitzonen abschaffen
Dann haben wir halt immer UTC
Wär ich auch sofort dabei
Zeitzonen sacken
Aktuell muss man sich ja auch immer
Überlegen
Ob wir plus 1 oder plus 2 sind
Ach so meinste das
Ja gut
Windows XP
Embedded
Ich muss ja sagen da wird ja immer viel drauf rumgehackt
Ich finde das prinzipiell gar nicht mal so schlimm
Wenn alte Systeme
Die gehen auf irgendwelche Embedded Dinger laufen
Die uralt sind
Das Problem ist nicht so sehr
Dass die damit laufen
Das Problem ist dass manchmal irgendwelche USB
Ports oder so exposed sind
Wo die Leute natürlich
Das Ding ratzfatz geknackt haben
Aber
Die eigentliche Sache
Dass
Das Zeug auf alte Hardware läuft ist ja nicht das Problem
Solange du nicht dran kommst
Weil mindestens nicht im Internet ist
Was ja auch bescheuert wäre Geldautomaten im Internet
Aber man darf halt auch nicht
Drankommen
Die übrigens die RMV
Das sind die
In meinen Verkehrsverbund
Picket Automat
Haben einen Raspberry Pi
Drinnen
Guck mal gibt sogar Pause
Zu habe ich auch schon morgens gesehen
Ja
Ja habe ich auch schon morgens gesehen
Wenn die Automaten
Rebooted haben
Die laufen auf Raspberry Pies
Das finde ich übrigens eine sehr sinnvolle
Überlegung
Weil ganz ehrlich
Du findest viel mehr Leute
Die sich ein bisschen mit Linux auskennen
Als Leute die irgendwelches embedded Zeug programmieren können
Du kannst das einfacher updaten
Du kannst die Software einfacher maintainen
Du hast Hardware Nachschub ohne Probleme
Du musst nicht irgendwelche super
20 jährigen
Wartungsverträge oder sowas abschließen
Und
Das ist halt easy
Und ganz ehrlich Rechenleistung
Braucht der Kram ja eh nicht
Jetzt mal seriously
Was braucht ein
Ich darf nicht vergessen
Was zu trinken
Ich meine ernsthaft
Was braucht ein Ticket Automat
Für Rechenleistung
Der kann auf Gameboy Hardware laufen
Oder auf noch älteren Dingern
Der braucht ja keine Rechenleistung
Der muss
Zwei Sachen berechnen oder so
Der braucht vor allem eher GPIOs
Zum ansteuern von
Drucker und Knöpfen
Und so Dingern
Da ist der Raspberry Pi ja auch gut
Das ist bestimmt kein Browser
Im Fullscreen
Die DB Anzeigetafel
Na gut die bei uns
Die sind teilweise ja noch richtig oldschool
Mit so einzelnen Pixel die du ansteuern kannst
Da ist was weiß ich
Ne aber wie gesagt also die RMV Ticket Automaten
Das hab ich auch schon gesehen
Die laufen auf
Raspberry Pi
Ja das hab ich auch schon gesehen
Was ich cool finde
McDonalds nimmt für ihre
Kartenanzeigen mittlerweile Windows 10
Was Kartenanzeigen
Welche Kartenanzeigen
Die die die
Überm Schalter wo du siehst was es heute kostet
Und sowas
Ich bin noch gar nicht
Aufgefallen dass das
Bildschirme sind
Ich dachte immer das sind Bilder
Aber vielleicht sind meine McDonalds auch einfach nur so rückständig
Also so alte
Steuerungsdinger würde mich das nicht wundern
Wobei dann eher Fortran
Als Kobold
Ja ganz ehrlich ich finde die Idee
Nicht verkehrt
Viel besser
Viel besser als du brauchst
20 Jahre Support Vertrag
Mit irgendeinem Embedded Ding
Wenn du dich entscheiden könntest zwischen
ASP.NET Core plus Server-Side-Render
Ganz ehrlich
Ich würde also
Ich geh mal in dem Fall davon aus
Dass du irgendwas hast was du sinnvoll
Server-Side-Render kannst
Also dass das nicht eine reine Klein-Anwendung ist
Wo sich irgendwelche Dinge updaten
Es gibt ja Anwendungen da macht es keinen Sinn Server-Side zu rendern
Zum Beispiel stellt euch
Irgendeine Chat-Anwendung vor oder stellt euch
Irgendwie ein Softphone oder sowas vor
Keine Ahnung da muss ja nichts Server-Side-Rendern
Also ich geh mal davon aus
Du hast Daten die du sinnvollerweise Server-Side-Rendern
Könntest weil ansonsten
Wird sich ja die Frage Server-Side-Rendering überhaupt nicht stellen
Was hältst du denn von
So eine Mischmasch wie das aktuell angesagt ist
Dass du eine ASP.NET Core Web-RP machst
Und
Ein Frontend mit Server-Side-Rendering
Also irgendwas
Von Svelte-Kit bis Nuxt bis
Next heißt das bei Vue glaube ich
Dass du quasi Server-Side-Render
Dass du die Seiten quasi vorrenderst
Auf dem Server
Dann rüber schickst zum Frontend
Und das Frontend sich über die AP weiter updatet
Das ist eigentlich
Das ist eigentlich das beste aus beiden Welten
Du hast
Schnellere Ladezeiten
Also beim ersten Seitenaufruf
Du kannst die Seiten ordentlich
Indizieren lassen von der Suchmaschine
Und
Jo das wars eigentlich
Was ist mit dem Lidl Tab
Das ist eine gute Frage was ist mit dem Lidl Tab
Steckdosenleiste Zigpie
Ahja die wollte ich mal irgendwann bestellen
Und gucken ob die was taugt ob man die mit dem Zigpie Stick
Betreiben kann die ich denn nicht habe
Aber ich muss sagen 3 Steckdosen
Guck dir mal warum ist hier nicht
Hat hier irgendjemand eine sinnvolle Erklärung warum es hier nicht einfach
Steckdosen gibt ich meine es ist jetzt ja nicht so
Als wäre hier kein Platz gewesen
Wir haben 4 USB warum macht man nicht einfach 4 ganz normale
230 Volt
Steckdosen
Du hast nichts verpasst
Er ist eingeschaltet
Vor ein paar Minuten Funst nur das Teil ist halt riesig
Ja
Ja gut was anderes kannst du eh nicht machen
Ja schon doch doch das ist doch nicht schlecht
Das passt doch
Auf ganz vielen embedded Dingern läuft Linux
Ich mein wir gehen jetzt ja nicht
Von irgendwelchen super krass
Abgespeckten Microcontroller Dingern
Wo du quasi
Dein C in Assembler
Übersetzt und das Ding direkt
Dann darauf bootest
Arduino mäßig
Das gibt es natürlich auch
Aber letztens beim Einkauf eine
Waage für Lebensmittel mit
OpenSuse gesehen wundert mich nicht
Ehrlich ich würde mein Kram
Also wenn ich Hersteller von sowas wäre
Ich würde mein Kram auch mit Raspberry
Palinierung bauen das macht es einfach viel einfacher
Leute zu finden und zu maintain
Das glaube ich nicht dass es damit
Was zu tun hat das wäre schon
Ich mein super das ist zwar China Chinesen
Rebrand Zeug aber das glaube ich trotzdem
Nicht dass es damit was zu tun hat
So
Also was gucken wir uns denn heute mal
Ich würde sagen wir lassen uns klassischerweise
Eine Runde von LevelCaptureBaiten oder
Der LevelCaptureBait
DICE LEARN THE LESSONS
Oh Mann
Wenn ich die Überschrift schon sehe
Ja wir wissen ja alle noch dass DICE
So committed ist auf Battlefield 2042
Die sind so committed dass die Internets
Anfangen das nächste Battlefield zu planen
So krass committed sind die
Also es ist im Prinzip genau das was ich gesagt
Habe
Die werden das Mindeste liefern
Was sie
Versprochen haben und quasi dafür
Zur Verantwortung gezogen
Wie auch immer man sich das vorstellen kann
Wo man sich darauf festlagern kann im Endeffekt
Die werden das Mindeste liefern also 4 Karten 4 Specialist
Und sonst keinen
Finger mehr krumm machen für Battlefield 2042
Hast du dir mehr Elden Ring angeguckt
Ja ich habe es mir sogar gekauft
Auf Steam zu Release
Einen Tag vor Release sogar ich habe es sogar preordert
Und habe es noch nicht gespielt
Ich habe
Von Elden Ring ziemlich viel Gutes gelesen
Vor allem die Spielwelt ich habe allerdings
Auch halt von vielen Leuten gehört
Die jetzt nicht so
Also was heißt von vielen ich habe 2 Reviews gesehen
Das waren beides keine hardcore
Souls Fans und die meinten ja ok
Die Welt und so das drum rum ist das alles geil
Aber das
Steuerungsfeeling ist halt gewöhnungsbedürftig
Wenn man nicht eh schon auf Souls
Games steht
Und ich war nie der riesen Soul Fan
Dark Souls und Demon
Souls und was gab es da noch
Sekiro und
Bloodborne und die haben ja so viele
Tausend Sachen mittlerweile gemacht
Aber was haben die noch gemacht
Das war es doch zum größten Teil oder
Story ist auch
Eintönig ja gut das wundert mich nicht
Die Story in Dark Souls
Ich habe mir mal so ein
Story Zusammenfassungsvideo angeguckt
Die war ja auch äußerst vage
Wenn man mal nett ist
Wobei nichts
Toppt
Wisst ihr was die Game
Serie ist mit der abgefucktesten
Story also ich meine damit jetzt nicht
Die gestörteste Story oder so die
Die wirrste
Undurchsichtigste
Sinnloseste
Und schlechteste und wirrste
Und überhaupt Story überhaupt
Wisst ihr welche Game Serie da ganz vorne mit dabei ist
Der Minecraft
Minecraft hat keine Story
Der Minecraft hat keine Story
Ratet mal
Was
Was könnte das sein also
Metal Gear Solid Nö
Da bin ich zwar kein Story Experte
Aber das geht schon klar
Path of Exile
Ja Path of Exile auch
Borderlands nein
Nein Kingdom Hearts Alter
Kingdom Hearts ist so mega abfuck
Das ist so das verstehen noch nicht mal die
Entwickler selbst mehr was da abgeht
Kingdom Hearts
Ist komplett im Arsch
Er gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn
Vor allem noch mit ihren zwischeneingeschobenen
Teilen 1.5
Und was auch immer
Ich verstehe das das Game einige Fans hatte gerade
Durch den ersten Teil
Das war ja mal ein Game
Wo es um Disney Sachen und Final Fantasy ging
Das ist vom dritten auch ein bisschen verloren gegangen
Aber storytechnisch
Ist das ein kompletter
Clusterfuck das Ding
Diese Woche war doch ein Stream
Den sieht man auf Twitch nicht mehr ja den habe ich gelöscht
Weil ich keinen Stream oben haben wollte
Wo ich zwischendurch 5 mal kacken musste
Und wer dabei war weiß ich war öfters
Mal kacken in dem Stream
Ich war den halben Stream gefühlt kacken
Wir lassen uns jetzt chibaden von Levelcap
Huge Levelcap
Chibade
Yebated
8 Minuten da ist nicht so viel passiert
Die Woche oder was falsches gegessen
Tja ich weiß es gar nicht mehr woran das
Gedenken aber ich war glaube ich
Mindestens 3 mal ich war glaube ich
3 mal im Stream auf dem Klo
Und dann auch irgendwie immer 10 Minuten
Oder so und am Ende
Musste ich gleich nochmal und habe gesagt
Ich mache jetzt aus
Der Feuermelder Stream
Soviel hast du glaube ich gar nicht
Verpasst
Wobei soviel hast du doch du hast das ganze Projekt
Verpasst das hat ja sogar am Ende funktioniert
So wir lassen uns mal Levelcapchibaden
Naja also EA
Wäre ja auch richtig richtig
Pepega dumm
Würden sie keine Changes machen
Vor Battlefield 2042
Ich mein
Also das sollte dem letzten
Stonks
Mann bei EA aufgefallen sein
Dass das nicht so gut war
Oder? Ich mein die haben sich
Jetzt heraus geredet mit Halo ist dran
Schuld wobei Halo auch keine
Irgendwie super
Krassen Spielzahlen mehr hat aber die
Ja
Aber
Ja der ist erkältet
Ja der hört sich echt erkältet
Ja das kommt an 2025
Oder so
Oh er hört sich echt gut an
Siehste
Das ist halt das Problem
Wenn dein Lebensunterhalt davon abhängt
Content zu createn
Da musst du ran ob du krank bist oder nicht
Ach nein
Ich glaub
Valuable lessons learned
Ist so eines der nicht sagen
Nicht sagensten Business
Dinger die die man sagen kann
Ich mein ihr kennt das
Wahrscheinlich auch von euch bei der Arbeit
Wenn irgendwas kaputt geht
Dann sagen die auch oder wenn irgendwas
Nicht funktioniert hat wenn irgendwie ein Projekt nicht
So geklappt hat oder sonst was dann sagen die ja
Immer sinngemäß das ist ja nicht schlimm
Wir haben da sehr viele Learnings draus mitgenommen
Oder sowas in der Richtung oder wir haben da sehr viel
Daraus gelernt oder sowas das ist im Prinzip
Einfach nur das eigene
Verkacken irgendwie schön geredet
Herzdruck zu Keller Dankeschön für den
Wir nehmen das mit
Ist ja wieder was anderes und das ist da auch so
Ich mein das ist einfach nur richtig
Dummes Geschwätze dass sie nicht wissen
Was sie machen haben sie jetzt ja nur wirklich bewiesen
Und warum sie auf einmal jetzt wieder
Die Erleuchtung haben sollen das
Hab ich so noch nicht verstanden
Aber nicht
Weil irgendjemand eingesehen hätte dort
Dass es eine schlechte Idee war
Das ist try and error jetzt
Und den Fans ein bisschen gut
Zureden dass sie den nächsten Scheiß wieder preorder
Nicht weil es irgendjemand eingesehen hätte
Geschweige denn weil es irgendjemand verstanden
Hätte
Die können im Prinzip so ziemlich
Alles von Battlefield 2042
Reversen anstatt
Das einzige
Chat
Was das einzige ist was sie beibehalten
Sollten aus Battlefield 2042
Feature
Jetzt nicht so sehr eins zu eins
Wie sie in Battlefield 2042 gemacht ist
Was ist das einzige eines der
Ich habe weder Corona
Noch bin ich Raucher
Sie sollten
Portal beibehalten
Nicht in dieser Version
Wie sie es jetzt haben da muss ich noch einiges tun
Aber Portal
An sich ist eine sinnvolle
Geschichte und ich bin nach wie vor davon
Überzeugt die
Beste Möglichkeit
Ein langlebiges Spiel zu erzeugen
Ist user created content
Mit natürlich ordentlichen Möglichkeiten
Kennt noch jemand den Starcraft Editor
Wo du
In Starcraft 2
Weiß ich nicht, ich kenne plus den noch aus Starcraft 1
Oder den Warcraft 3 Editor
Du konntest da drin
Mehr oder weniger das komplette Spiel
Neu, also selbst bauen
Und sowas ist
Halt mega nice
Das wird dafür sorgen
Dass die Spieler
Wenn das Grundgerüst gut ist
Dass die Spieler über Jahre
Guckt euch Half Life 1 an
Jahrzehnte
Neuen Content erstellen
Und das gespielt wird
Müsste das nicht weiter runtergehen
Naja gut, das sind wahrscheinlich irgendwelche
Level Bots
Dass man auf Ebay Level 100
Accounts verkaufen kann oder was auch immer
Keine Ahnung ob er das noch spielt
Man müsste es eigentlich mal wieder anmachen und spielen
Und gucken ob man noch Portal Surfer findet oder so
Nächster Teil
Ich glaube nicht
Dass sie so ein aktuelles Ereignis
In den Battlefield einbauen
Wobei wenn man das richtig macht
Könnte man das machen, aber da sind zu viele Leute getriggert
Das glaube ich nicht
Was ich aber mir gut vorstellen könnte
Ist, dass das nächste
Battlefield eventuell
Ich hoffe es nicht
Und hoffe es gleichermaßen nicht
Dass das nächste Battlefield 2023
Raus kommt
Weil Call of Duty
2023 eine Auszeit hat
Und das würde natürlich
Gut passen
Das Problem ist jetzt nur
Dass die da jetzt eigentlich schon ziemlich tief in der Entwicklung
Stecken müssten
Was sie ja nicht machen und das wieder sonst so ein Schnellschuss wird
Emergeden Sie 4
Weiß ich nicht was das ist
Sagt mir nix
Emergeden Sie 4
Das klingt wie Krankenwagensimulator oder so
Umo und ich habe keine Ahnung wer das ist
Aber wahrscheinlich was in Frankfurt
Ja nächstes Jahr
Kommt kein Call of Duty raus
Ich weiß gar nicht ob das offiziell jetzt schon ist
Oder ob das auch nur Leaks sind
Aber die wollten jetzt ja auf
Einen etwas längeren Release
Cycle hinwirken
Ist das offiziell schon bestätigt?
Ich bin gar nicht sicher jetzt
Was
Chat sagt wenn wir Pech haben kommt
Battlefield zu uns und das vor
Du meinst jetzt Real Life technisch
Na da glaube ich eher nicht
Wenn du dir überlegst wie lange die Russen da jetzt brauchen
Bis die hier sind
Das ist ja mal was ganz was Neues
Das eine Shotgun in Battlefield nicht so
Funktioniert wie gedacht
Das kam ja noch nie vor
Das ist free to play
Ich dachte man muss das kaufen
Ich hab das damals gebacked
Aber gut
Free to play ist auch das einzige
Wie du nennst
Spielerzahlen da generieren kannst
Ganz davon abgesehen
Die hätten ja selbst nie gedacht
Dass sie mal mehr Spieler haben als
Battlefield 2042
Das Problem ist nur sie haben nicht wirklich mehr Spieler
Als Battlefield 2042 die haben ungefähr genauso viele
Spieler wie Battlefield 2042
Und es ist beides nicht viel
Das ist auch nicht der Battlefield
Ersatz hier für viele
Und es ist auch nicht so groß
Durch die Decke gehen
Was ist das?
Okay das heißt
Noch mehr Content Recycle
Auf der anderen Seite muss ich sagen
Die Maps waren mir durchaus lieber
Als manch neue Maps
Ich mein ganz ehrlich
Die Modern Warfare 1 Maps
Es gab ein paar
Brauchbare
Aber die meisten waren einfach nur
Riesen großer Verwinkel der Müll
Hat mir überhaupt nicht gefallen
Und an jeder Ecke
Hat einer um die Ecke gegeiert
Und sowas
Aber Modern Warfare 1 wusste
Ehe nicht so genau was es sein wollte
Arcade Call of Duty
Run and Gun
Oder eher wir schleichen uns
Von Deckung zu Deckung
Die wussten es nicht so genau
Hat World War 3
Immer noch diesen komischen
Russischen Anti-Cheat
Ja das letzte Mal als ich das ausprobiert habe
Hatten immer noch mail.ru Anti-Cheat
Wo ich bis zu dem damaligen Zeitpunkt
Gar nicht wusste dass mail.ru
Anti-Cheat überhaupt ein Ding ist
Ich bin immer wenn ich diesen Clip sehe
Der hat mich schon beim Modern Warfare Trailer
Oder beim Warzone was auch immer das war
Trailer getriggert
Ich mein warum
Muss die auf die Motorhaube
Klettern um in das Auto rein
Zu schießen
Es ist jetzt ja nicht so dass man nicht vom Winkel
Das Auto hätte von vorne auch durchlöchern können
Und gerade in einer Stadt
Die umkämpft ist, expose ich mich doch nicht
Indem ich aufs Auto renne
Und dann in die Windschutzscheibe schieße
Ich mein es sieht halt stylischer aus
Okay das lass ich mir gefallen
Aber das ist was wo ich mir jedesmal denke so innerlich
Wer hat sich gedacht
Dass das eine gute Idee ist
Ein besserer Winkel
Ja weil du auch so einen krassen Winkel brauchst
Um von vorne rein zu ballern
Wenn die Karre losfährt
Und du stehst auf der Motorhaube
Ist auch nicht wirklich viel besser
Warzone
warzone underwent its latest round
Of cheater bans this week as well
According to the developers at Raven Software
Over 90.000 Accounts were banned
This is undoubtedly one of the largest
Bandwaves the game has received
Since it launched its Ricochet Anti-Cheat
Software last year
Even with such a high banned
The devs still have a long way to go
Everyday new hacks and cheats
Are used to exploit the game
Not so wie Battlefield 2042
Wo die Cheat Hersteller sogar sagen
Nein wir produzieren keine Cheats mehr
Das hab ich noch nie erlebt übrigens
Ich hab es noch nie erlebt
Bei einem Spiel von einem halbwegs populären
Franchise, dass innerhalb von
3 Monaten oder so
Die Cheat Hersteller gesagt haben
Wir verkaufen keine updated Cheats mehr
So schlecht
Das musst du erstmal hinkriegen
Dass Cheat Hersteller sagen nein
Wir updaten unsere Cheats nicht mehr
Das ist absolut Wahnsinn
Also die haben das auf so
Viel lebend und verkackt
Wahnsinn
Ja gut Snoop Dogg ist dabei
Snoop Dogg ist jetzt
Ist er nicht
Ist er nicht G2 gejoint
Nee warte mal
Für wen streamt
Faze nicht G2
Okay warum nicht
Ganz davon abgesehen
Das ist einzig und allein für den Meme Faktor
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen
Dass Faze an seinen
Madden 2022 Streams
Sonderlich interessiert ist
Also wer das nicht weiß
Der Kerl hat ja wirklich
Einen Twitch Channel
Auf dem er
Madden streamt
Nur Madden
Oh oh
Merke Kona
Merke Kona geht eigentlich nicht
Nur Football
Also deswegen
Hat ihn Faze bestimmt nicht
Der ist
Das ist einfach für den Meme Faktor
Am besten
Am besten Leute wo ich immer lachen muss
Ist immer noch das hier
Passt mal auf
Wie sehr also
Auf das Gameplay gucken
Ihr müsst auf das Gameplay gucken
Der Kerl ist eine Minute lang
Nur in diesem Kram und läuft vorwärts und rückwärts
Sonst nichts
Schaut euch das Gameplay an
Alter ich will das Gameplay sehen
Das Video ist dumm
Der Typ ist legit die ganze Zeit hier nur hin und her gelaufen
Vorwärts rückwärts
Das ganze Gameplay hast du von dem gesehen
Das ist vorwärts rückwärts in diesem Kram
Sonst nichts
Schaut euch das Gameplay an
Vorwärts rückwärts
Mensch das ist alles so kacke geschnitten
Wobei das war jetzt der real life
Über die Übertragung
Aber das ist so geil
Der hat einfach nichts gemacht
Außer hin und zurück laufen
Stimmt
Stimmt in Ghosts gab es das Snoop Dogg Voice Pack
Ich erinnere mich
Bei der Gelegenheit fällt mir ein
Gab es nicht irgendwie einen Battlefield mit Kollegen als Sprecher
War das nicht so
Das war Hardline oder
War das nicht Hardline
Das hat es auf jeden Fall nicht rausgerissen
Ob Money Boy
sich besser geschlagen hätte
Schei
Ich kann Österreicher
Österreicher sind schlecht da
Die sagen halt Schei
Schei
Wie sagen Österreicher Schei
Die knatschen das irgendwie so
Ok neue Switcher Game
Ja gut dazu weiß man ja nichts
Außer dass es
entwickelt wird
CD Projekt Red
Die Entwickler von Cyberpunk 2077
haben eine neue Switcher Game entwickelt
Die neue Game wird
eine neue Saga für die Franchise
und wird nicht den Switcher 4 genannt
Es wird mit
Ja das haben die ja auch schon gesagt
Vor einer ganzen Schaas
Ja so ähnlich aber eher so äh so geknatscht
Ich kann Österreich nicht nachmachen
Die haben ja mal vor
Jahren gesagt
Das ja wohl Witcher 3 das letzte Spiel
Das letzte Witcher Game mit Geralt sein soll
Aber im Ernst was interessiert die
Was die vor 5, 6 Jahren gesagt haben
Who cares
Und wenn die denken Geralt zählt besser
Dann ist Geralt wieder am Start
Und es wird auf Unreal Engine
5, 4 oder 5
Es wird auf jeden Fall auf Unreal Engine basieren
Ja genau
Kann ich aber auch verstehen
Nachdem die mit Cyberpunk
So auf die Nase gefallen sind
Und wahrscheinlich jetzt auch an den Limits sind
Und du findest natürlich auch
Einfacher Leute
Für Unreal
Deswegen wisst ihr was
Ich glaube DICE würde auch besser damit fahren
Battlefield in Unreal zu entwickeln
Normalerweise könnte man sagen
DICE ist quasi die Erfinder
Die Erfinder von Frostbite
Und die haben Battlefield Erfahrung
Aber das letzte Battlefield
Hat gezeigt DICE hat selbst keine Ahnung
Mehr von ihrem eigenen Kram
Die Leute sind weg
Und die neuen Leute haben noch keine Ahnung
Und du findest garantiert einfacher
Leute mit Unreal Erfahrung
Als Leute die Erfahrung mit Frostbite haben
Beziehungsweise die Zeit die sie brauchen
Zum sich einarbeiten in Frostbite
Also wahrscheinlich wäre es durchaus
Sinnvoller das nächste Battlefield
In Unreal zu entwickeln
Aber es ist jetzt ja nicht so als würde man das großartig merken
Es sieht nicht alles gleich aus
Das ist ja die Sache
Du wirst bei den meisten Spielen
Du kannst überhaupt nicht sagen auf welche Engine
Du kannst, ich meine
Bei den ganzen schlechten Unity Games
Die dann auch Unity im Logo vorne drin haben
Ja da kannst du sagen das ist Unity
Aber wende dir mal hier
Was weiß ich, wende dir die Top
Man müsste sich die Top 500 Games angucken
Steam Seller
Da sagst du, ich meine
Bei ein paar hat man Vermutungen woran das liegt
Bei ein paar Sachen erkennst du es
Beziehungsweise kannst du es vermuten
Woran das liegt
Also ein RPG Maker Game
Erkennst du meistens als ein RPG Maker Game
Oder solche Geschichten
Aber ansonsten
Es ist nicht so, dass das jetzt nicht auch Unreal sein könnte
Oder so
Letztendlich hat die Optik
Und die Engine darunter
Jetzt nicht allzu viel miteinander zu tun
Höchstens auf
Technologischer Ebene
Auf welche Sachen du einfach
Zugreifen kannst und welche Sachen du einfach verwenden kannst
Aber ansonsten
Rein an der Optik erkennst du es nicht
Ob das Unreal ist, ob das Unity ist
Was auch immer ist
Und insofern
Ist es wahrscheinlich
Sinnvoller Unreal zu verwenden
Oder meinetwegen
Die könnten das neue Battlefield auch in Unity machen
Meinetwegen
Da müsste es
Wobei ich halt keine Ahnung hab
Wie gut default Unity für Shooter ist
Beziehungsweise
Aber die müssen am Endeffekt
Das Game drum herum stricken
Also keine Ahnung
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es
Aus dem aktuellen Gesichtspunkt
Dass sie selbst mit ihrer eigenen Frostbite
Geschichten nicht mehr durchblicken
Wahrscheinlich sinnvoller wäre und effektiver wäre
Den Kram einfach in Unreal zu programmieren
Solange es nicht Source ist
Warum? Source ist eigentlich nicht schlecht gewesen
Source hatte zumindest
Einen super Modding Support
Also mit Half Life und dadurch
Sau viele Leute, die sich mit Source auskratten
Jetzt ist, sag mal mal so, in den letzten Jahren
Ist die Source Engine vielleicht nicht mehr
Ähm
So verbreitet, ich glaube das einzige Source Game
Was in den letzten Jahren rausgekommen ist
War Titanfall
Weil ich mir da gar nicht sicher bin
Ob Titanfall immer noch Source war
Das Zweier, wahrscheinlich
Ähm
Source Engine Games
Gucken wir mal, ja Apex, Apex, genau
Das ist ja von den, von den
Titanfall Typen
Gucken wir mal
Ja
Ja gut, Black Mesa
Das wissen wir
Das, das war irgendein Strategiespiel, oder?
Nee, dann bringe ich es jetzt durcheinander
Keine Ahnung
Sagt mir nichts
In Search die, ja okay also die
Okay, Titanfall ist nicht dabei
Weil es so modified war
Gut, da also Source ist jetzt bestimmt nicht mehr
Das, der Shit
2022, aber warum
nicht
Wenn man sich damit auskennt
Aber ich denke auch mal die Entwicklertools sind einfach
Bei Unity und Unreal mittlerweile viel besser
Ja also mal davon absehen
Ich finde es eine sinnvolle Sache, dass die Witcher
Viel in Unreal machen und wahrscheinlich wäre
Es für DICE auch besser
Gerade im Punkt, wo Leute finden, die Ahnung davon
Haben, wenn sie einfach Unity
Oder Unreal verwenden würden. Wahrscheinlich liegt die
Unreal mehr
Und noch eine Sache, die mir gerade noch zu einfällt
Witcher 4 auf Unreal
Ein Vorteil, den die
Haben ist, die sind
Bekannt, die sind groß, Witcher ist eine
Riesen Marke mittlerweile
Und wenn die
Von Epic Games Unterstützung
Brauchen, die kriegen die
Im Zweifelsfall setzt Epic Games
Auch 20 Leute dahin, die nichts
Anderes machen, als denen beim entwickeln
Von Witcher 4 helfen
Das kostet natürlich ein bisschen was und die machen das bestimmt
Auch nicht ganz selbstlos
Unreal ist Paintchamp wegen C++
Frostbite ist auch C++
Ich glaube Frostbite ist eine Mischung
Aus, zumindest wenn man
Den Modding Tools glaubt, den fan erstellten Modding Tools
Eine Mischung aus C++
Und Lua immer noch
Das ist richtig oldschool shit
Ja, Scheißzeitumstellung sehe ich auch so
Go plays
Sie wollen ihre Anti-Cheat und mehr Manual-Bands ausfüllen.
Die Spieler hoffen für eine Kernel-Level Anti-Cheat, ähnlich wie Warzone's Ricochet System.
Playstation hat noch ein Spielstudio gekauft.
Das Montreal-Base-Studio Havn wurde im März letztes Jahr eröffnet.
Jade Raymond ist die Co-Kreatorin der Assassin's Creed-Franchise.
Sie hat auch eine Hand in die Watchdog-Serie.
Die Devs sind auf dem Weg, um ein neues, AAA-Multiplayer-Spiel zu eröffnen.
Und seit Playstation das Studio gekauft hat, haben sie jetzt Hilfe von anderen Playstation-Studios wie Naughty Dog und Insomniac Games.
Wenn es um Team Xbox geht, werden Räumnisse über neue Hardware dieses Jahr eröffnet.
Diese Räumnisse sind aus dem Xbox-Ära-Podcast ausgelöst.
Einer der Hosts sagt, dass Microsoft so bald wie möglich neue Hardware revealieren möchte.
Er sagt auch, dass es nicht wie erwartet werden wird.
Xbox Series X und S-Consoles und die weltweite Chipschortage. Eine neue Konsole sieht unwahrscheinlich aus.
Es kann sich nicht spekulieren, dass es eine Art Streaming-Dongel sein könnte, um Game Pass-Titles über den Cloud zu spielen.
Alternativ, andere Rumoren zeigen, dass Xbox eine neue Kontrolle eröffnen könnte, die mehr in Bezug auf den DualSense-Kontroller der Playstation 5 ist.
Destiny-Kontakte-Kreatoren und Streamer auf YouTube haben sich mit dem Destiny-Soundtrack sehr große Copyright-Einschlüsse vorgelegt.
Einige Kreatoren wurden sogar gezwungen, mehrere Videos aufzunehmen.
Bungie hat das Problem erkannt, dass sie die Copyright-Einschlüsse nicht eröffnen.
Bizarre ist, dass Bungie sich selber mehrere Copyright-Einschlüsse auf ihre eigenen Videos gegeben hat.
Und während der Ursprung dieses Copyright-Einschlüsses...
Das ist ja geil!
Die Entwickler bekommen selbst Copyright-Strikes für ihre eigene Game-Musik.
Das ist natürlich nicht schlecht.
... ist unklar.
Die Spieler denken, dass es vielleicht ein Algorithm-Malfunktion oder etwas zu tun hat mit der aktuellen Acquisition der Playstation 5.
Hat Bungie und der Halo-Komponist nicht irgendwie eine Klage laufen oder so?
Wobei, ich weiß nicht, ob der Typ auch Destiny-Musik gemacht hat. Keine Ahnung.
Team17, der Publisher von Hell Let Loose, hat sich mit Indie-Studio-Small-Impact-Games geteilt.
Zusammen arbeiten sie auf einen neuen Spacepiraten-Taktischen Looter-Schütter namens The Rotters.
Team17, ist das nicht mit Worms?
Wobei, vielleicht hat er das auch gerade gesagt. Ich habe ihm nicht zugehört.
Sind das nicht die mit Worms, die jetzt gesagt haben, sie machen Worms mit NFTs?
Und dann haben alle gesagt, nein, wir wollen kein Worms mit NFTs.
Und dann haben sie gesagt, ja, wir machen kein Worms mit NFTs und jetzt machen sie doch was mit NFTs.
Sind sie doch, oder?
... ist set in einen alternativen 1990s, wo die große Krieg nie endete.
Um den Konflikt zu erholen, fließt die Menschheit zu den Stars, die sich um Refuge suchen.
Die Spieler übernehmen die Rolle von Spacemersenaren, die unterschiedliche Gegner auslösen und zerstören.
Die Spieler haben auch die Möglichkeit, andere Spieler-Schiffe zu zerstören und zu zerstören.
Während der Zerstörung wird ein limited amount of oxygen supplied.
Wenn es zerstört wird, wird die Gegner-Schippe zerstört.
The Rotters werden später dieses Jahr auf Steam in Early Access gestartet.
Wir würden gerne eure Gedanken auf Tom Henderson's neuestes Leak hören.
Willst du ein neues modernes Battlefield-Spiel nächstes Jahr oder ist es zu spät?
Wenn es darum geht, was ich spielen will,
dann will ich nächstes Jahr ein neues, modernes Battlefield in Good spielen.
Das Problem ist nur, das ist ja wieder kaum Entwicklungszeit.
Also, ich glaube, ich muss dazu ein eigenes Video machen später.
2042, lasst uns wissen, was ihr in den Kommentaren denkt.
Das sehr populäre Action-Adventure-Spiel, Plague Tale Innocence, wird in ein...
Ja, juckt mich nicht.
Chat, habt ihr die Halo-Serie gesehen?
Oder habt ihr die ersten Folge oder die ersten zwei Folgen der Halo-Serie gesehen?
Ich werde nicht spoilern, weil ich hab sie nicht geguckt.
Ich möchte jetzt mal von euch wissen, lohnt sich das,
die Halo-Serie sich zu besorgen und zu gucken?
Keiner.
Also, ich hab, was ich bisher gelesen hab, ist recht gemischt.
Viele sagen halt, ja, okay, nice, es ist unverkennbar Sachen von Halo übernommen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite sagen auch viele so wirklich,
warum ist man so weit weg von den Games gegangen?
Zum Beispiel muss es ja wohl sein, dass der Master Chief ohne Helm rumrennt und so was.
Dass der Master Chief irgendwie, äh, klein ist,
in der ersten Folge sagt, er führt seine Befehle nicht aus, wobei der Master Chief...
Ich meine, wer die ersten paar Halo-Dinger gespielt hat,
der Master Chief ist quasi der Inbegriff von, äh,
es ploppt eine Mission auf dem Bildschirm aus, ich führe die aus.
Mal gucken.
Vielleicht guck ich mir die trotzdem an.
Das hab ich mir auch gekauft auf Steam und noch nicht gespielt.
Was, in Frankreich?
Ich glaube, ich muss heute doch ein Video machen.
Ich wollte eigentlich nicht zu dieser Geschichte mit vielleicht neues Battlefield,
äh, weil, eigentlich, wenn man ehrlich ist, gibt es da nicht wirklich viel dazu zu sagen.
Aber drumherum gibt es dann doch ein paar Dinger.
Ich hab gesagt, es gibt nicht wirklich viel dazu zu sagen,
aber es gibt noch ein paar Dinge, die ich noch nicht so gerne erzählen kann.
Es gibt noch ein paar Dinger.
Ich hab gesagt, der Master Chief läuft ohne Helm, aber fuck.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich hab's mir gekauft auf Steam,
aber ich hab's noch nicht gespielt.
Ich glaube, ich hab's zwei Minuten gestartet und dann nicht weitergespielt.
Dazu bräuchte ich noch ein paar Mythen.
Ich hab ja fast alles abgearbeitet, wobei, ich hab ja so...
ein Mix-Dokument mit einigen Sachen drin.
Aber ich glaube, die sind nicht, wie soll ich sagen, aufregend, neu genug.
Es gibt ja nicht unendlich viele.
Unreal ist 20 Jahre... Ja, Moment, das Original Unreal,
das hat ja mit der Fünfer jetzt so wenig am Hut.
Oder um was geht's?
Weil Game-Engines alt sind.
Ach, hier.
Wieso gibt es keine großen Game-Engines in Python oder Rast?
Das liegt zum größten Teil daran, würde ich mal sagen,
erstens, weil die Platzhirsche eben da sind.
Und es ist deswegen dementsprechend schwierig,
noch was Zusätzliches zu etablieren.
Ich meine, Unity hat jetzt auch irgendwie was,
zehn Jahre gebraucht, um sich dorthin zu etablieren, wo sie sind.
Und das Problem dürfte wahrscheinlich Python und Rast selber sein.
Es gibt ja 2D-Game-Engines in Python,
aber das ist jetzt eher nicht so das, womit ich jetzt vielleicht
das nächste Battlefield machen würde.
Die Sache ist, die Python selber willst du nicht
als hauptsächliche Kern deines Games haben.
Das ist einfach lahm.
Man könnte das natürlich benutzen als Script-Geschichte
für Interfaces oder sowas, ja, vielleicht,
aber sicherlich nicht für die Kernlogik.
Da ist Python einfach langsam, und Python ist mega langsam.
Was man machen könnte, ist, so wie das Unity macht mit C Sharp,
Python zu C++ übersetzen und dann kompilieren.
Vielleicht, vielleicht würde das funktionieren.
Und mich würde nicht sogar wundern,
wenn es nicht sogar schon Game-Engines gäbe,
die das anbieten.
Weiß ich nicht, wie spricht man das aus?
Godot oder so?
Kann man da Python als Scripting-Language verwenden?
Die haben auch verschiedene, was haben die?
Nee, die haben den Script, C Sharp,
C++ und C. Also, das könnte man vielleicht machen.
Und Rust ist das Ding.
Rust selber ist, glaube ich, einfach noch zur Nische.
Rust ist zur Nische, und Rust ist kompliziert as fuck.
Rust ist dafür da, oder Rust ist gut dafür,
sagen wir mal, sicherheitskritische Sachen.
Ja, beispielsweise eine Browser-Render-Engine
oder Browser-CSS-Zeug oder sowas zu programmieren,
wie das Mozilla gemacht hat.
Oder Rust mag auch gut sein, um Server-Site,
Security-Sachen zu... was auch immer.
Also, Dinge, die halt wirklich keine Memory-Leaks haben sollen,
trotzdem schnell sein müssen.
Aber ich glaube, Rust ist nicht das Richtige für Games.
Bei Games ist der Sicherheitsaspekt,
sprich, dass das keine Overflows gibt.
Das ist, wie immer, nicht so entscheidend.
Bei Games ist entscheidend, dass das muss fast as fuck sein,
auch wenn es im Zweifelsfall mal irgendwo...
wenn irgendwie was...
Games dürfen durchaus crashen,
wenn halt was ganz Unvorhergesehenes passiert.
Und...
Rust hat halt den Trade-off von
kompliziert,
dafür, sagen wir mal,
fehlerfreier,
aber halt kompliziert.
Und ich glaube, Rust ist nicht die Sprache,
wo man in einer Game-Engine
als hauptsächliche Sprache mit glücklich werden würde.
Wobei es mich...
nicht wundern würde, wenn es nicht sogar schon Versuche gibt,
dass da was in Rust zu basteln.
Also...
Ja, ich denke mal, das dürften so die Hauptgründe sein.
So genau, wie gesagt, ich bin kein Game-Entwickler, keine Ahnung.
Das reime ich mir jetzt einfach nur zusammen.
Ja.
Ja, und dass Unreal 20 Jahre alt ist,
ist in dem Fall ja auch ein Vorteil.
Ich meine, Unreal schreckt mich natürlich C++ ab.
C++ ist abfuck extrem.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass Unreal vielleicht C++
mit eigenen Sachen ein bisschen erträglicher macht.
Keine Ahnung, habe ich noch nie...
Ich bin kein Spieler-Entwickler, keine Ahnung.
Der Vorteil von Unreal
oder auch der Vorteil von Unity ist,
so wie ich das als Außensteher sehe, ist,
du hast Leute mit jahrzehntelanger Erfahrung im Zweifelsfall
oder, sag mal so, dadurch, dass es ebenso Leute gibt,
gibt es auch sau viele Beispiele, Tutorials,
Dokumentation, Webcasts und sonstige Geschichten,
um Unreal und Unity zu lernen.
Und deswegen sind die Dinge halt auch da, wo sie heute sind.
Zumal man ja auch sagen muss, Epic Games
steckt ja da auch richtig viele Ressourcen und Geld rein.
Also die, bevor es Fortnite gab,
haben die damit ja, oder wobei ich weiß es gar nicht,
ob die mit der Engine oder Fortnite mehr verdienen,
aber bevor es Fortnite gab, haben die mit eigenen Games
und vor allem der Unreal Engine Geld verdient.
Chris Sawyer einstellen und alles das selbe.
Ist das der Typ mit Rollercoaster Tycoon?
Ja, Rollercoaster Tycoon.
Leute, der Typ ist Massive Brained.
Das erste Rollercoaster Tycoon ist die Logik
komplett in Assembler programmiert.
Muss ich mal vorstellen, dass der Typ ist,
das Gehirn von dem ist implodiert wahrscheinlich danach,
als der fertig war.
Nee, hab ich nicht, hab ich auch nicht vor.
Nee, die haben noch kein neues angekündigt.
Aktuell sind das nur interne Leaks.
Der Typ hat aber meistens recht gehabt mit dem,
was er geleakt hat.
Und es wäre ja auch logisch, dass man jetzt schon
am nächsten Battlefield arbeitet.
Gerade nach dem Reihenfall und man sich jetzt...
Also es gibt ja zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder Battlefield 2042 war mega gut angekommen.
Man hätte einen nicht unbeachtlichen Teil
des Entwicklerteams behalten für neuen Content
und Microtransactions und Geschiss.
Oder aber man lässt sie am neuen Spiel entwickeln.
Nachdem das so beschissen angekommen ist,
ja, wunderts mich nicht.
Dass man das jetzt macht.
Okay.
Dann könnte, ja, genau.
Wenn die Unreal verwenden,
können sie ihr nächstes Game Pass Stack Overflow zusammen.
Ja, hab ich, hab ich schon.
Qt ist das einzig Sinnvolle.
Okay, das ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Mittlerweile hast du ja auch noch so was wie Flutter
und Electron und sonst was.
Aber ja, das spielt der andere Liga.
Qt ist das einzige Desktop-Cross-Plattform,
UI-Framework, was irgendwie Sinn macht.
Aus meiner Sicht.
Wenn man wirklich Cross-Plattform machen will
mit der gleichen Anwendung.
Also wenn du die gleiche Anwendung laufen lassen willst,
Windows, Mac, Linux,
und du es nicht in JavaScript,
Electron machen willst,
oder nicht kannst,
oder Flutter Desktop, der nur nicht weit genug ist,
bleibt dir außer Qt nichts anderes übrig.
Ja, das war richtig pock.
Wisst ihr, was ich auch richtig, richtig geil fand damals?
Das war das erste Theme Park.
Nicht das.
Das erste.
Das da, genau.
Das fand ich auch mega damals.
xhackyx, danke schön für den Zap.
Ja, das stimmt wohl.
Wobei es Flutter technisch mobile ja wohl ganz gut aussieht,
aber Flutter auf dem Desktop ist doch so halbe, halbe, ja.
Ohne Scheiß, mein Rechner ist geschaut,
ich hab mal einen Macbook mit einem PS5,
wie soll ich mir einen neuen, geilen Rechner...
Tja, gar nicht aktuell.
Übrigens, habt ihr es mitbekommen?
M-Cross-Account wurde gehackt,
hab ich gestern auf YouTube gesehen.
Ich geh da jetzt nicht drauf,
weil ich keine Werbung machen will für Krypto-Scam.
Oder ist wohl gerade dabei, den wiederzubekommen.
Richtig feels Batman.
Massive feels Batman.
Ja, für good ist es...
Ja gut, C++ ist halt auch abfuck.
So Leute, wir gucken mal weiter.
Was haben wir sonst noch zu gucken?
Also, Levelcap hat uns schon gebadet.
I use Arch on an M1 Macbook, by the way.
Okay, wir lassen uns eine Runde Fireship gebaden noch.
It is March 26th, 2022, and you are watching the code report.
I use Arch, by the way.
By the way, ich übrigens auch.
Was denkst du über Rust?
Ja, hab ich mich ja gerade schon drüber ausgelassen.
Rust an sich ist eine wirklich sinnvolle Geschichte,
gerade für security-relevante Sachen,
so wie beispielsweise Mozilla das in Firefox verwendet,
wo du dir halt wirklich sicher sein musst,
es gibt keine Overflows
und es ist am Ende keine Sachen mehr unaufgeräumt,
es laufen nicht irgendwelche Threads länger als sie laufen sollen und sowas,
plus gleichermaßen halt ebenso schnell wie es geht.
Dafür ist Rust gut, ich glaube aber nicht,
und da hatten wir es ja gerade von,
dass das die passende Sprache ist, um Spiele zu entwickeln.
Bist du eigentlich mit deinem Android-Server fertig oder kommt da noch was?
Weder noch, also ich hab jetzt nicht geplant,
dass wir dann demnächst noch was mit streamen,
aber er ist auch nicht fertig.
Team Accession, das bezieht sich auf was?
Okay, Arch, by the way.
By the way, it's a phrase reserved for the most elite
and disciplined Linux users,
and it's completely off limits to all...
Arch, by the way, das ist einfach nur für die
größten high IQ Leute, die Linux verwenden.
...soy devs on our MacBook Pros.
Until now, because just last week,
a new Linux distro called Asahi
has brought the Linux experience to Apple Silicon.
I couldn't believe it myself, so I did some investigative developing
and dropped two grand on a MacBook Pro to try it out for this video.
What I found was absolutely shocking.
It actually worked somewhat okay for the most part.
Apple Silicon has been a game changer in the computing world,
which uses bleeding edge technology to create blazingly fast chips
with the ARM architecture.
And blazingly fast is no exaggeration here.
They're literally the most powerful consumer chips on the market.
There's just one small problem.
Like everything in Apple, they live within a walled garden,
which means you can really only run Mac OS on those chips,
primarily because it's missing drivers to do anything useful,
and there's virtually no documentation to figure things out.
However, everything we're doing here is perfectly legal,
and there's no jailbreaking involved.
It's not like iOS, where the bootloader is locked down,
to prevent you from loading another operating system on it.
M1 MacBooks give you access to the bootloader,
but don't expect a great developer experience working with it.
Asahi means rising sun in Japanese,
not to be confused with the beer of the same name.
It comes from a team with a lot of experience
bringing Linux to weird places, like the PlayStation.
It just had its first alpha release a few days ago,
so buckle up for the Asahi Linux experience.
First, my mom took me to the local Apple store
so I could use my birthday money to purchase a MacBook Pro
with a state-of-the-art M1 chip.
After that, we had lunch at the Olive Garden.
When I got home, I opened it and immediately entered the command
to install Asahi Linux.
Git wasn't installed, so it recommended I install Xcode,
which took a couple of hours.
Once that was done, I tried again,
but then needed to update my system to Mac OS Monterey.
That took another couple of hours.
Once that was done, the command finally worked.
When you start it up, it will take you through a variety of options,
but most importantly, it will make a partition on your hard drive
to install a completely separate operating system.
What you'll end up with is a dual boot system
with Mac OS on one side and Linux on the other.
The entire process took about a half hour,
and I just went with the default options.
Most importantly, at the end,
it gives you instructions about how to boot up the system.
You'll need to hold down the power button for 15 seconds,
which will eventually bring you to a screen
with multiple boot options.
Choose Asahi, and it will bring you into Arch,
running the KDE Plasma desktop.
It also comes with a setup wizard,
which is basically cheating if you want to call yourself a...
Ich könnte mir aber vorstellen,
super krass performant läuft das immer noch nicht da drauf,
weil die haben keine Grafikkartentreiber,
dementsprechend keine 3D- und 2D-Beschleunigung,
und, ja gut, die CPU funktioniert halt so,
wie die eben funktioniert.
Läuft das?
Da hab ich meine Zweifel.
Also das letzte, was mir einfallen würde,
um das zu testen, ist Node.js installieren
und ein bisschen Java, okay, aber auch nicht.
Siehst du, von wegen, der Chat eben wieder,
der Chat, doch läuft es.
20 Sekunden später sagt der Video,
GPU-Unterstützung ist kacke, ja.
Was denn du?
Hat ich doch recht.
Hätte mich auch nämlich sehr gewundert.
Es gibt keine Video-Acceleration.
Klar, es gibt keine 2D-3D-Acceleration.
Klar, wenn es keine gescheiten GPU-Tragungen gibt.
Es gibt kein HDMI.
Klar, Thunderbolt-Displayport.
Ist doch klar, das wird es wahrscheinlich
auch auf absehbare Zeit jetzt erstmal nicht geben.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich so immer wieder
paar kleine Patches, die nach und nach
vielleicht HDMI-Support, Thunderbolt-Support
oder so reinpatchen, aber du hast...
Ich glaube, man muss, glaube ich, nicht davon ausgehen,
dass es irgendwie eine ordentliche Doku gibt,
wie man Treiber oder was denn diese Grafikkarte
da drin überhaupt erwartet.
Das weiß Apple und es weiß Apple und Apple
und vielleicht noch ein paar Leute bei Apple,
aber ansonsten weiß das keiner.
Arch, by the way.
Das ist der Grund, warum ich auch Arch-Linux verwende.
Nur most elite Linux-User verwenden das, genau.
Alles, was ein MacBook ausmacht, geht nicht.
Das ist richtig.
Dafür ist Richard Stallman wahrscheinlich happy.
Aber man kann nicht alles haben.
By the way, wisst ihr eigentlich auch,
dass es nicht Linux heißt?
Ich warte jetzt eigentlich nur auf die Copypasta da drauf.
Genau.
Aber eigentlich ist es auch kein Linux.
So sieht es aus, ja.
Hier habt ihr es.
Also es ist genug bloß Linux, ja.
Okay, weiter geht's. Was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Zeige ich mal her, was haben wir denn jetzt?
Was ist das?
Warum habe ich das aufgemacht?
Lego Omelette Reis, Lego in Real Life,
Stop Motion Cooking und ASMR.
Warum? Ich habe 2 Minuten und 55.
Ich erkenne genau, dass das keine Lego Paprika ist.
Jetzt ist es eine Lego Paprika.
Alter, wie aufwendig muss das sein, so etwas zu erstellen?
Der hat wahrscheinlich 3 Tage gebraucht für 2 Minuten und 55.
Krass, ich glaube, das ist übelst aufwendig.
Das muss richtig aufwendig sein.
Aber es sieht gut aus. Das hat er wirklich gut gemacht.
Sogar das tropft runter.
Die Lego Teile sind zusammengeklebt, seht ihr das?
Die Lego Teile sind zusammengeklebt mit irgendeinem Schaum.
Das sieht nicht aus wie Heißkleber.
Das ist irgendein Schaum, Knete, Sahne, keine Ahnung.
Diese Animation hier schon.
Der weiß auch, was er macht.
Jetzt kommt noch ein Ei drauf.
Das ist nicht schlecht.
Das ist wirklich nicht ohne gewesen, das zu machen.
Ich kann es mir einfach nur extrem aufwendig vor, so etwas zu filmen.
Krasser Scheiß.
Was es nicht alles so auf YouTube gibt.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht schlecht.
Warum sehen die DLC Kurse schlechter aus als die Original Kurse?
Weil Nintendo wahrscheinlich.
Was möchte ihr mir das Video jetzt sagen?
Da bin ich zu low IQ für, da bin ich zu dumm, das zu verstehen.
Das ist wirklich eine Sus-Referenz.
Ihr könnt das nicht verstehen.
Hast du schon mal das Spiel Windows Frame gesehen?
Nein.
Klingt nach irgendwas, das meine Dateien löscht oder so.
Nee, sagt mir nichts.
Hier ist das Windows Frame Game.
Ist das da?
Hier gibt es sogar ein Video.
Ah, du bewegst.
Die Idee ist etwas Innovatives.
Deine Kamera ist dein Windows Fenster.
Das sieht nach einem Feature aus, was mich nach zwei Minuten nervt.
Aber kann es nicht sein, dass es gut gemacht ist?
Nee, sagt mir gar nichts.
Das habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Funktioniert das über mehrere Monitore?
Was weiß ich?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wobei, doch, warum nicht?
Du kannst ja auch Windows Fenster über mehrere Monitore machen.
Das ist kein Ding.
Das funktioniert ohne Probleme.
Ist TVFix ein Scam?
Ja, hier ist why.
Das wurde mir heute Morgen empfohlen, dass ich das angucken soll.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob TVFix ein Scam ist.
Wahrscheinlich, weil er sagt ja, es ist ein Scam.
Was haben wir sonst noch zur Auswahl?
Fortnite und Co.
Was Geld verdienen als Kommentator für eSport lohnt sich das?
Ja, das gucken wir uns gleich noch an.
Home Automation, sonst was.
Ich will aber erst mal wissen, was TVFix ist.
Ist mir egal, ob das Fortnite ist.
Ich finde diese Serie gar nicht schlecht von denen.
Ich glaube, das ist sogar ein öffentlich-rechtlicher YouTube-Channel.
Ich will erst mal wissen, was TVFix macht.
Das ist eine Scambox, die beispielsweise sagt, wenn ihr die kauft, könnt ihr alles umsonst gucken.
Alter, schreine ich, warum?
Sponsored by Linode.
And it's time for some more Scambusting.
Today we're taking a look at the TVFix, which claims to give you access to tons of TV-Channels for free.
Also wenn einer zu mir sagt, nimm diese kleine Kiste und du bekriegst ganz viele TV-Channels, die sonst was kosten umsonst, dann sage ich dann...
Oder ich sage zu ihm...
Und werde das garantiert nicht an meinen Fernseher anschließen.
And it's 100% legal.
Ganz bestimmt, ganz bestimmt ist es legal.
Okay, ich predicte jetzt mal kurz, was das Ding ist.
Mal gucken, ob das stimmt.
Also ich gehe davon aus, dass das eine ganz billige, low-end Android-TV-Box ist.
Aber wirklich ganz, ganz low-end.
Also quasi so schlecht, dass du 720p nicht richtig abspielen lässt.
Und darauf ist irgendwie, genau, Samstagnachmittag, sowas würde ich auch vermuten.
Und darauf ist irgendeine Android-App, die über Torrent Filme rauf und runter lädt.
Weil ganz ehrlich, die scheißen doch drauf, ob es legal ist oder nicht.
Also ich denke, das ist ein Android-TV mit einem Torrent-Client im Endeffekt.
Sodass du erstmal direkt in den Knast kommst, wenn du es anschließt und verwendest.
In den Knast nicht, aber erst mal 20 Abmahnungen bekommst.
Was? Moment, Moment, Moment, das ist auf Deutsch.
Das verstehen wir ja sogar mal.
Dieses Video ist jetzt Deutsch.
Nach zahlreichen Testrunden waren die Ergebnisse verplüffend.
Nach zahlreichen Testrunden, als sind die damit im Kreis gefahren auf irgendeiner Rennstrecke.
Wisst ihr was sein könnte, warum das in Deutsch ist?
Weil international ja viele immer noch denken so nach dem Motto,
Deutsche wären besonders effizient und besonders qualitativ und sowas.
Er lässt dich bis zu 100, 800 Premium- und internationale Kanäle schauen wahrscheinlich.
Mit Sicherheit, wer von euch hat nicht auch so eine TV-Hack-TV-Fix daheim?
Alles klar.
Natürlich. Ja, mit Sicherheit.
Das ist äußerst sus, wenn einer was erzählt in der Richtung.
Das ist sehr, sehr fragwürdig immer.
Jetzt fehlt bloß noch irgendwie, das wird auch im Weltraum verwendet oder irgendwie so ein Scheiß, ja.
Zuerst, ok, ok, was? Der Jakob Arlos, alles klar.
Wahrscheinlich ein gehackter Twitter-Account.
Leute, ich sag euch, da fehlt jetzt wirklich bloß noch, dass die erzählen, es wird in der Weltraum,
in der Raumfahrt schon lange verwendet oder so ein Stuss.
Das erzählen die auch immer, immer gerne.
Ok, also was sagt denn zuerst?
Habe ich nicht geglaubt, dass eine solche Technologie existiert.
Ja, weil da bestimmt auch so viel drinne ist in dieser kleinen Box.
Da ist irgendein Low-Low-Low-End-Entroy-TV drinne wahrscheinlich.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob es den gibt?
JAL234, JAL234.
Ne, wir suchen direkt auf Twitter, wer weiß, wo der noch rumscammed.
Ne, das bin ich.
Da will ich nicht hin.
JAL.
Da ist er.
Den gibt es tatsächlich.
Oder PostedFishMac oder sowas.
Alles klar.
Den Typ gibt es tatsächlich.
Moment, der ist seit März 2022 auf Twitter.
Das ist schon mal Sus.
Von wann ist das Video?
Angeblich hat er das März 2021.
Das ist ein Fake-Account.
Das ist irgendein, das ist irgendein Account, den jemand erstellt hat,
nachdem er das Video gesehen hat wahrscheinlich.
Das ist Sus.
Sehr, sehr, sehr verdächtig hier.
So.
Also was hat er denn geschrieben?
Zuerst habe ich nicht geglaubt, dass eine solche Technologie existiert.
Aber ich war verpüft, als ich meinen Fernseher einschalte und ein klares Bild von...
Ah ja, also man schaltet ihn einfach ein und auf einmal zeigt dein Fernseher dann 600 Kanäle an, oder wie?
Seems legit.
Militärtechnologie.
Ich habe doch gesagt, das ist aus der Raumfahrt.
Aber nein, es ist Militärtechnologie.
Wenn es nicht aus der Raumfahrt ist, dann ist es Militärtechnologie.
Das haben die auch immer gerne.
Diese ganzen Scam-Dinger, es ist immer der exakt gleiche Scheiß.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als letztens irgendwie...
Wie hieß dieses Ding?
Super...
Super Wifi oder sowas?
Wir haben doch letztens ein Video geguckt, wo die...
Wie hieß denn das Ding?
Wir haben doch letztens ein Video geguckt, wo die erzählt haben,
dass du...
Da konntest du auch WLAN technisch irgendwas...
Dein Internet ver...
Genau, ich weiß es wieder, ich weiß es wieder.
Letztens haben wir ein Video geguckt zu einem Scam-Produkt, die...
Weil das WLAN...
Weil doch angeblich die Provider das WLAN extra schlecht machen bei einem daheim.
Und da gab es ein Produkt, das musste man einfach nur einstecken.
Und das sorgt dann dafür, dass quasi die WLAN-Router der Provider alle anlockt werden
in den unschlecht gemachten Zustand oder sowas.
Was ein Bullshit!
Haben wir letztens erst geguckt?
Keine Ahnung, es ist glaube ich noch keine zwei, drei Monate her.
Alles Müll, Alter.
Alles Müll, natürlich.
Na, wo haben sie die her?
Für die Ad.
Haben sie mal durchgescrollt, so my dirty hobby.
Durchgescrollt, nickt einer angeschrieben.
Willst du für uns nicht einen Werbespot machen?
Nee, das muss ja sein.
Ja, das ist ja auch immer so.
Ja, das ist meistens Scam.
Das ist meistens Scam.
MTV?
Gibt es das überhaupt noch?
Ja, was weiß denn ein Hersteller in Deutschland, wie Comedy Central jetzt neuerdings aussieht?
Gar nicht.
Also legal ist es definitiv nie und technisch possible, wie gesagt.
Ich denke immer noch, das ist halt Low, Low, Lowend-Android-TV mit irgendeiner blöden Torrent-App drauf.
Okay, es ist tatsächlich so, irgendein Typ hat es nachdem er das Video gesehen hat, hat er den Account angelegt.
Videorekorder.
Ich mein, theoretisch geht das.
Du kriegst in dieses Ding ohne Probleme 2TB Speicher rein.
Das ist halt nicht schnell.
Und auch nicht langlebig.
Rein kriegst du's.
Oder es geht über irgendeinen Cloud-Service.
Aber ich vermute nach wie vor immer noch, das ist ne billige Android-TV-Box mit irgendeiner Torrent-App drauf. Fertig.
Und die sagen halt dann, runterladen ist quasi recorden oder sowas.
Natürlich, das ist ja immer so.
Übrigens, gleiche Taktik verwenden ja auch Pay-to-win-MMOs und sowas.
So nach dem Motto, jetzt im Angebot 100 Rubine für den Preis von 500.
Aber nur heute und dann ist ein Ticker daneben dran, noch 5 Minuten, noch 4,59, noch 4,58.
Und nachdem es abgelaufen ist und du machst das wieder auf, fängt es zufälligerweise wieder bei 5,59.
4 of missing out, genau.
Im Prinzip ist es ja so, die ganzen Scammer, die jetzt im Internet sind,
die haben ja schon Jahrhunderte Erfahrung quasi im Scammen, nicht im Internet.
Und die ganzen Maschen haben sich ja nicht großartig geändert.
Außer, dass es jetzt eben angepasst ist ans Internet.
Ich habe euch ja schon von dem Business von meinem Vater erzählt, wie er früher versucht hat, Leute zu scammen.
Also, ich kenne mich da aus erster Hand aus, wie das aussieht, wenn jemand versucht, Leute zu scammen.
I found this advertorial written by Michael McKinney, who is likely just a fake name paired with a stock photo,
like I've seen in previous Scambusters.
The advertorial, or in this case, fake article, claims...
Wie denn?
Das habe ich, okay, nur mal für die Leute, die nicht dabei waren.
Mein Vater hatte früher eine Partnervermittlung in Frankfurt.
Das ist schon lange her, 1990 rum oder so muss das gewesen sein.
Er hatte eine Partnervermittlung in Frankfurt und der hat halt keine Partner vermittelt.
Das war noch weit, weit vor Internet und solche Geschichten.
Der hat halt im Prinzip geguckt, dass er irgendwelche Omas findet,
die seit zehn Jahren oder so auf der Suche sind nach einem neuen Kerl,
hat hier einen Vertrag unterschreiben lassen, der halt sehr, sehr einseitig war.
Vor Gericht müssen Sie wohl eine der Omas gefragt haben, sagen Sie mal, warum haben Sie das überhaupt unterschrieben?
Der war ja sogar vor Gericht wegen Scam-Geschichten damals.
Und, also wenn der Richter einen fragt, so nach dem Motto, wie können Sie denn sowas unterschreiben?
Dann, naja, weißt du schon, und deswegen ist übrigens auch die übliche Masche heute mit dem Enkeltrick,
du versuchst natürlich Omas zu veräppeln oder so, was heißt Omas?
Omas, sagen wir mal so, ältere Damen zu veräppeln, das war nämlich alles Omas.
Also vielleicht damals auch schon 50 plus.
Und was er halt gemacht hat ist, er hat den ja auch nie wirklich versprochen,
also der Vertrag war halt wirklich äußerst einseitig, im Prinzip hat er sich ja auf nichts festgelegt.
So, und die haben Mitgliedergebühren bezahlt und er hat ihnen dann halt Kandidaten vermittelt.
Nur die Sache war halt die, es wurden nie wirklich Kandidaten vermittelt mit dem Ziel,
dass die quasi dann, ähm, ja, zu vermitteln an die Damen.
Der hatte, der hatte, was weiß ich, vier, fünf Typen, so im passenden Alter,
alle gut ausgeschaut, alle gute Manieren gehabt, alle konnten gut reden.
Und diese vier, fünf Typen, die sind dann halt vermittelt worden an alle Damen.
Und die hatten halt das Gefühl, dass quasi die wahnsinnig viel machen dort bei dieser Partnervermittlung.
So nach dem Motto, im Wochentag gibt es neue, hübsche, nette Typen, die sich für mich interessieren.
Und in Wirklichkeit ging es ja einfach nur darum, dass die Omas richtig viel Geld abdrücken.
Und die haben ihn ja damals wohl auch angezeigt und da ist freigesprochen worden.
Also die Verträge waren wohl wasserdicht.
Das ist halt alles.
Und diese Maschen, das ist ja alles der gleiche Scheiß.
Und heute halt im Internet.
Deswegen muss man sich eh mal überlegen, auch bei Partnervermittlungen im Internet,
wie viel Interesse haben die daran, dich wirklich zu vermitteln, wenn du einen Monatsbetrag bezahlst?
Also eigentlich müsste man die, und da hab ich gesehen, gibt es jetzt die ersten, die das machen,
eigentlich müsstest du die für erfolgreiche Vermittlung bezahlen.
Also du müsstest die quasi nur bezahlen, wenn, oder sag mal mal so, die müssten vielleicht einen Mindestbetrag, okay,
die müssten aber eigentlich nur bezahlt werden, wenn die erfolgreich dir wen vermittelt haben.
Dann hätten die ein gewisses Interesse dran.
Es ist ähnlich, das kannst du auf ganz viele Sachen übertragen.
Überlegt euch mal, wie viel Interesse daran hat ein Medikamentenhersteller?
Wann genommen ihr habt eine Krankheit, an der ihr sterbt, außer ihr nehmt Medikamente?
So, wie viel Interesse daran hat ein Medikamentenhersteller, ein Medikament rauszubringen,
was euch wirklich gesund macht, nachdem ihr das eine Weile genommen habt?
Oder, versus, ihr müsst euer ganzes Leben diesen Kram nehmen,
sodass ihr nach Möglichkeit eine normale, lange Lebenserwartung habt, dass euch auch gut geht und sonst was.
Also wenn die die Auswahl haben zwischen dem einen oder dem anderen, ist doch klar, dass die rein erstmal,
und ich rede hier nur von rein von Geld, also sprich, wenn man es rein aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht betrachtet,
da müssten die ja dafür sorgen, dass du lebenslang den Scheiß nimmst, dass sie lebenslang Geld von dir bekommen,
und es dir gut geht, dass du möglichst alt wirst.
Das heißt, die dürften daran eigentlich wenig Interesse haben.
Es sei denn, es gibt irgendwelche Regularien und sonstige Sachen, die sie davon abhalten.
Aber normalerweise wird man erstmal sagen, hey, normalerweise sollten die wenig Interesse daran haben.
Und ich will jetzt kein, bevor mir jetzt irgendjemand ankommt, ich will jetzt keinen Bogen hier spannen, von wegen Corona-Impfung, bringt nichts oder sowas.
Das ist ganz im Gegenteil.
Aber rein aus dieser Stonks-Sicht, warum sollten die was herstellen, was dich gesund macht, versus du musst das dein Leben lang nehmen?
Wie heißt man, ja, komm in meine Telegram-Gruppe, genau.
Ja, Shadow-Enemy, genau, also gerade bei chronischen Sachen ist halt auch die Frage, vielleicht ist es nach aktuellen medizinischem Stand auch gar nicht möglich, das zu heilen.
Und dann ist die nächste Frage, wie viel Interesse hat man denn an der Forschung, es zu heilen versus man hat ein Medikament, was dafür sorgt, dass Patienten lebenslang damit leben können, relativ problemlos.
Versus ich forsche dafür, dass wir vielleicht es heilen können irgendwann.
Sobald ein Konkurrent halt als besseres Mittel hat, verkaufen die das halt nicht mehr.
Ja, ja und nein, ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, also nachweisen kann man das natürlich nicht, ich wäre mir da gar nicht so sicher, wie viele da wirklich nicht unter einer Decke stecken,
zumal es ja auch nicht so viele gibt in diesen Bereichen, gerade wenn es um Forschung geht an seltenen Sachen,
da wird es wahrscheinlich weltweit nicht 250 verschiedene Dinge geben, die sich da Konkurrenz machen können, da hast du vielleicht 2-3 Sachen, die da in der Lage sind und das Money haben, das zu machen.
Und alle werden wahrscheinlich relativ ähnlich denken, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die unter einer Decke stecken müssen.
Also wenn du die Auswahl hast zwischen nimm drei Monate was und du bist gesund oder nimmst dein Leben lang,
dann kann ich mir das als Medikamentenhersteller ganz klar, rein aus Stocksicht, gut vorstellen, dass man sagt, warum, will ich nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Krankenkasse in der Lage ist zu forschen und seltene Krankheiten dafür was zu erfinden.
Wenn die das wären, dann bräuchtest du die ganzen Medikamentenhersteller nicht.
Das kannst du aber auch vieles übertragen.
Also das kannst du genauso gut sagen, welches Interesse hat ein Arzt, dich zu behandeln, so dass es dir wieder gut geht, versus du kommst einmal im Monat und drückst Geld ab.
Ich rede jetzt nicht von gesetzlich Versicherten, weil dafür kriegen sie eh kein Geld.
Das sind Sachen, ich will nicht sagen, dass es passiert im großen Stil oder so, aber das ist etwas, was man sich echt mal überlegen muss.
Wo ist der Anreiz dafür, was zu erfinden, wenn du mit der anderen Sache, die schon da ist, viel mehr Geld machen kannst?
Und da gibt es bestimmt Antworten drauf in manchen Bereichen und manchmal ist es sicherlich auch so, dass genau das gemacht wird.
Das forschen vielleicht nicht lukrativ genug ist, weil man sagt, hey guck mal, es reicht ja was wir haben, alles mögliche.
Letztendlich ist es immer stonks, was zählt.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich da jetzt drauf gekommen bin.
Achso, ja, dass die Scam-Masche immer die gleiche ist.
Genau, die Scam-Maschen sind immer die gleichen.
Das ist immer dieser gleiche Müll von kauf jetzt, morgen gibt es nichts mehr oder verrate es nicht weiter.
Hier gibt es die einzig wahre Methode, irgendwie reich zu werden.
Der Scam ist immer der gleiche.
Und warum ist der Scam immer der gleiche?
Weil es bewährte Methoden sind, wo die Leute drauf reinfallen.
Es ist ja mittlerweile bekannt, auf welche Maschen viele Leute reinfallen.
Man muss sich ja mal überlegen, es ist doch gut, wenn da bloß die blöden Leute drauf reinfallen.
Die kannst du dann noch weiter ausnehmen.
Oder was meint ihr, warum dich die ganzen Scammer auch immer möglichst einfache Opfer suchen?
Du kannst Scammen ja auf zwei verschiedene Varianten.
Entweder du machst es einfach möglichst breit und aggressiv, zum Beispiel der nigerianische Prinz, wo du irgendwelche Sachen geerbt hast.
Dann schicken die Millionen Milliarden Spam-Mails in der Hoffnung, dass vielleicht irgendeiner so doof ist
und tatsächlich 800 Euro überweist für die Transaktionsgebühren, die er braucht für seine 2 Milliarden.
Das ist die eine Variante.
Oder du suchst dir gezielt Leute raus, so wie das beispielsweise auch in Spielen mit Microtransaktions funktioniert.
Ich habe letztens ein Video darüber gesehen, das war ein Interview mit einem Free2Play-Developer,
der bei irgendeinem Free2Play-Spiel gearbeitet hat und die haben gesagt,
die gingen so weit, dass die explizit analysiert haben, wer sind die Leute, die in unserem Spiel besonders viel Geld ausgeben
und haben dann dort Sachen eingebaut, explizit für diese Leute.
Die hatten zum Beispiel jemand aus, ich glaube Saudi-Arabien, der hat dieses Spiel gespielt
und die haben festgestellt, die sind zudem auf die Facebook-Seite, die haben geguckt, wer ist das, die sind zudem auf die Facebook-Seite,
haben festgestellt, ach guck mal, der Typ ist Fußballfan und sein Lieblingsfußballclub hat, ich sag jetzt mal, Orangenfarben
und dann haben die explizit Microtransaktions eingebaut und diesem Typ promoted mit den Lieblingsfarben von seinen Fußballclub
und er hat den Scheiß gekauft.
Und genauso suchen sich die Leute von wegen Enkeltrick, Handwerkertrick, was auch immer,
die suchen sich immer Leute raus, wo das einfach geht.
Was meint ihr denn, warum immer so viele Omas gescampt werden?
Weil die Leute denken, und was ja wohl auch greifbar sein muss, sonst würden sie es nicht machen,
weil die Scammer denken, du kannst Omas und Opas am Telefon eben besonders gut scammen,
vielleicht weil sie auch von moderner Technik keine Ahnung haben, vielleicht weil sie generell ein bisschen langsamer sind, was Auffassung angeht
und stellen euch noch mal vor, habe ich letztens wieder gelesen bei der Polizei Frankfurt, auf Twitter war das glaube ich,
sie haben einen 90-jährigen Typ, 90-jährigen Opa angerufen daheim und haben gesagt, sie sind von der Polizei
und, ich mache kurz ein bisschen Musik an, sie sind von der Polizei
und seine Tochter wäre in einen Autounfall verwickelt mit Todesfolge und sie sitzt jetzt im Gefängnis
und nur wenn er irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 5000 Euro Kaution bezahlt, kommt sie frei.
Und dann ist dann dort eine hingefahren zu dem Opa, der Opa ist hin, hat Geld zusammengekratzt bei sich aus der Schublade,
dann ist dann eine hin, eine Scammerin hin mit Polizeieuniform und hat von dem Opa das Geld abgeholt
und hat gesagt, ja sie kommt jetzt gleich mit der Tochter vorbei, sie kam natürlich nie
und das ganze ist nur rausgekommen, weil die sich danach noch mal gemeldet haben und noch mehr Geld haben wollten
und dann ist es dem Opa gedämmert, dass das komisch ist und er hat die Polizei gerufen.
Die haben hier jetzt in dem gleichen Haus, wo ich wohne, hatte früher mal ein Opa gewohnt
und da war er auch, nachdem die Oma gestorben ist ein paar Jahre alleine in dem Haus, den haben die auch mal gescampt.
Da waren irgendwelche Lederjacken-Verkäufer am Start, die haben gesagt, sie kennen mich, die haben gesagt,
sie sind Freunde von ihrem Enkel, also von mir, was ja Bullshit ist, als hätte ich irgendwelche Lederjacken-Verkäufer-Freunde.
Mal davon abgesehen, ich habe überhaupt keine Freunde.
Einmal ganz davon abgesehen, haben die dem erzählt, sie kennen mich und da hat er gesagt, ja was ist denn,
der kennt ja durchaus die ein oder anderen Real-Life-Freunde von mir noch von früher, aber das waren halt keiner von denen
und dann hat er gesagt, ja kommen sie rein, kommen sie rein und dann wollten die dem auf einmal irgendwelche seltenen Lederjacken verkaufen.
So random, stell dir mal vor, jetzt überleg dir mal, wie das ankommt, es klingelt jemand bei dir an der Tür und sagt,
ich bin Freund von deinem Enkel, du sagst, ja komm rein und auf einmal sagt, der will zu Lederjacke kaufen.
Zumindest, die haben das so gemacht, wie die meinen Opa gescampt haben, der eine hat eben versucht Lederjacken zu verkaufen
und der andere ist aufs Klo und hat das Haus durchsucht nach Wertgegenständen und als die weg waren,
die wissen natürlich, wo sie suchen müssen sofort und als die wieder weg waren, hat sich dann rausgestellt,
die haben irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 800 Euro mitgenommen oder so, sonst nichts, der Typ ist oben ins Schlafzimmer gegangen,
hat die Kommode aufgemacht, da wo die Leute standardmäßig ihr Zeug haben, haben durchgeguckt, haben Sachen gefunden,
haben Sachen gefunden, aber sie haben sie nicht erwischt, sie haben nur Sachen gefunden, die sie weggeworfen haben,
also beispielsweise irgendwelche Ausweise und sonst was.
Und das ist halt immer wieder der gleiche, immer wieder der gleiche Scam, immer wieder die gleichen Maschen.
So, genug Gelaar, wir gucken jetzt weiter. Also sobald irgendjemand erzählt so nach dem Motto,
ah nur noch heute kriegst du irgendwas oder nur wir haben das einzig wahre oder erzähl es bloß nicht weiter
und solche Geschichten oder so nach dem Motto, 10 Jahre geforscht und jetzt ist die neue Technologie da,
du bist der Erste und du musst alles Scammen, alles für den Arsch, einfach komplett ignorieren am besten.
Aber er lässt unbekannte Freunde einfach so in die Wohnung, ja ältere Leute zum Beispiel, die total überrumpelt sind.
Fake Handwerker ist auch so ein Ding, klingeln sie bei dir an der Tür und sagen, ja wir sind von den Heizungsableisern
und dann sagst du, hä, also ich kann mich nicht dran erinnern, dass Heizungsableise angekündigt sind
und dann sagen die sowas in der Richtung wie, ja das passiert öfters, dass die Briefe verloren gehen,
aber wenn sie uns jetzt nicht reinlassen, dann müssen sie den nächsten Termin selbst bezahlen
und was meint ihr, wie viele Leute dann sagen, naja komm, da gehen sie mal schnell an die Heizung,
am besten noch wenn sie dich gerade beim Mittagessen machen erwischen, dass du nicht gucken kannst, was abgeht,
dann sagst du, ah gut, kommen sie rein, gehen sie schnell an die Heizung, lesen sie ab und zack.
Die wissen genau, wo sie gucken müssen, die sind auch schnell, was das angeht, der Typ geht rein,
zack, nimmt nebenbei was mit und ist 200 Euro reicher, fertig, das kriegst du gar nicht richtig mit.
Und natürlich suchen die sich dann auch explizit aus, wo die hingehen.
Die werden bestimmt nicht bei jemand klingeln und dann den Scam durchziehen, so ein 2 Meter Schrank,
der aussieht wie Arnold Schwarzenegger und in der Tür steht, weil da haben die zu viel Schiss,
wenn die in der Wohnung erwischt werden, dass der ihn aufs Maul haut.
Die werden dann wahrscheinlich bei der alleinerziehenden Mutter klingeln,
wo eh schon gerade Krach aus der Wohnung kommt, die eh gerade am Mittagessen machen ist
und sagen, ja, wir sind von den Heizungsablesern, dürfen wir kurz rein,
bis nächsten Termin müssen sie selbst bezahlen und dann sagt die, ja, kommen sie rein,
gucken sie schnell an die Heizung, kriegt es gar nicht mit und selbst wenn sie die erwischt,
was sollen sie machen? Die hauen einfach ab und rennen weg, die kann ja gar nicht festhalten oder so,
geschweige denn denen irgendwas tun. Die suchen sich immer schon absichtlich die gewisse Opfer raus
und das ist halt auch das, was ich da wirklich extrem assi finde bei sowas.
Ja und die Maschen sind immer die gleichen, egal.
Ja, das ist auch immer so ein typisches Scam Ding, so nach dem Motto, wir haben jetzt hier was ganz tolles Neues entdeckt,
aber nicht weiter sagen, nicht weiter sagen, weil das darf eigentlich gar keiner wissen,
wir schreiben es öffentlich ins Internet, aber eigentlich darf das gar keiner wissen,
weil wenn die es wüssten, dann müssten sie ja was dagegen machen. Alles Bullshit immer.
Ja, natürlich.
Über den HDMI-Kabel hackt sich das in meinen Fernseher, alles klar. Wie? Nicht?
Was übrigens auch ein Scam ist, der immer funktioniert, ist, wenn man sagt,
die Alert-Sounds bei Amazon Prime-Subs funktionieren nicht mehr.
Kann das sein, dass die Alert-Sounds kaputt sind, wenn man Prime-Subbt?
Und es gibt immer Leute, die probieren es aus.
Es gibt immer Leute, die probieren es aus.
Like, likely fake, ja, das kann man so sagen, aber die sind, die sind sehr wie das Arme in der Kirche, sind die fake.
Die haben die Webseite nicht mehr angepasst von ihrem alten Scam-Produkt.
XMQX, danke für den Sub.
MarkCN, Dankeschön. Subscriptions hier. Du fällst absichtlich drauf rein.
Ja, ich habe auch keine Schmerzen damit, wenn die Leute es absichtlich machen.
Ist mir sogar noch lieber. Geht doch noch, lol.
Die haben ihre Scam-Webseite vom alten nicht angepasst.
Dankeschön, Marius, danke für den Sub. Hustelbaron, Dankeschön.
Wisst ihr, das ist, das, genau so, das ist doch eigentlich noch besser. Die Leute wissen, dass man sie baiten will und machen es absichtlich.
Lachoh, neun Monate, ich use Subscriptions hier.
Green Talbot, Dankeschön.
Creo TV, jetzt geht es aber ab hier. Lasst euch mal...
Jetzt... Der Abo-Scam ist raus.
Danke für die Subs, lol.
Stonks, Big-Subscription-Stonks.
Verkauf uns keine Lederjagen, ne, ne.
Ne, ne, die Masche bei mir ist nicht Lederjagen, die Masche bei mir ist die Abo-Falle. Du kannst jetzt erst mal nicht mehr kündigen.
Falls du nicht die AGBs gelesen hast, selber schuld.
Nein, natürlich könnte ich kündigen, immer was geht.
More inconsistencies equals more red flags.
While searching online, I found another video from a familiar, literally loud-mouthed narrator.
Welcome to all of you...
Der Microsoft Support ist am Start, Alter.
In this new video.
Der Microsoft Support ist am Start, fuck.
Warum wundert mich das nicht, dass das irgendein Scam in der Video ist?
More clickbaity facial expressions and arrows. Wow, I've never seen those before.
I bring this video up, because it does something that the other stuff doesn't.
It actually talks about the legalities a little bit more, but pretty vaguely.
TVFix is a brand new... Warum ist das immer... Warum müssen das immer Scam in der sein? Ja, ich mein... Manchmal wird's ja mit Vorurteilen übertrieben.
Aber die schaffen das echt immer wieder zu bestätigen. Warum müssen das immer in der Scam sein?
Wahrscheinlich hat der Typ, der dahinter steht, das ausgelagert nach Fiverr. Mache ein Review-Video, Fiverr-Auftrag.
100% legal. Ja, das klingt äußerst vertrauenserweckend.
Ja, genau.
The device takes advantage of a loophole, which is... Ist das hier... Guck mal, wie groß das gefotoshopped ist.
Guck mal, das Ding ist so groß wie die halbe Wand, Alter. Dabei ist das so groß wie irgendwie... So lang wie ein Finger normalerweise.
Alles klar. Ja, gut, irgendwelche Stock-Fotos davor.
Alles klar.
Scumbag.
Okay, das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken. Ich meine, es gibt vier Sachen. Im Prinzip DVBC, DVB-T, DVB-S. Ist das Satellit? Und IPTV. Fertig.
So, also das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht angucken. Wir wissen, wie das funktioniert.
Ja. Das wissen wir, wie das funktioniert.
Wie gesagt, ich denke immer noch, dass es ein Low-Budget, Low-Low-Low-End-Android-TV ist mit vorinstallierter Torrent-Torrent-App, die sich dann irgendwelche aktuellen Filme runterlädt. Illegal.
Gewatsch. Es ist doch klar, dass sie das nicht machen.
11 Videos Einleitung, ja, stimmt schon.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie lang der eigentliche Test geht. Zwei Sekunden.
Ja, ach nee. Weiter, weiter, weiter, weiter.
Jetzt kriegen wir auch noch erklärt, wie Satellitenschüssel funktionieren. MonkaS.
Gar nicht. Gar nicht.
Ja, das ist normal. Das kommt auch immer. Kaufe drei, bekomme ein Satellit.
Ja, das ist normal. Das kommt auch immer. Kaufe drei, bekomme eins umsonst.
Ja.
Ich will eigentlich nur wissen, ob ich recht habe, dass es billig ist mit Android-TV mit Torrent-Client.
So ein ähnliches Ding haben wir uns letztens auch ein Video zu angeguckt. Wo wir das Video zugeguckt haben, ging es darum, dass irgendwelche Provider-Router unlockt werden, die ja angeblich absichtlich dann WLAN schlechter machen und so was.
Da mal. Zeigt er jetzt noch was zu dem Ding? MonkaS. Ach ja. Nach zehn Minuten. Wie? Das war's jetzt?
Krasse, krasser Test.
Okay, es ist doch nicht mal eine Android-TV-Box.
Haben die den? Haben die den Playstation-Update-Hintergrund geklaut? Ist das nicht der Playstation-Update-Hintergrund?
Sieht irgendwie so genau, sieht irgendwie ähnlich aus. Ja, toll. Es ist noch nicht mal, es ist noch nicht mal das, was ich gesagt habe, es ist noch nicht mal eine Android-TV-Box.
Es ist nichts davon, es funktioniert noch nicht mal, es macht noch nicht mal das, was es machen soll.
Na gut, was auch sein kann ist, das ist so eine Art Chromecast und man muss jetzt auf seinem iPhone die Torrent-App installieren.
Oder auf seinem iPhone gibt es sowas weniger. Du musst auf deinem Android-Handy, Tablet, PC vielleicht eine Torrent-App installieren, zum Rüber-Streamen.
Boah, das sieht schon beschissen aus.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass ihr, dass ihr in dem Bowling, weil ich mir gar nicht mehr sicher bin, ob es das Wii, doch das war das originale Wii-Bowling, glaube ich.
In irgendeinem Bowling war es nicht möglich, den Ball ins linke auszuwerfen.
Oder war es die Kegel nicht links zu treffen? Links ins Aus oder die Kegel links zu treffen? Eins ging bei Wii-Bowling nicht.
Ja, und weiter? Laggy, laggy.
Okay, ganz ehrlich, das Video war jetzt auch halber Scam. Ich mein, wir wussten doch von Anfang an schon, dass es nicht nix taucht. Ja gut, aber selbst die Vorstellung war nicht sonderlich geil.
Ach, ich weiß nicht. Auf YouTube sind heute die meisten Videos auch halb Scam.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir uns was an. Fortnite und Co. Geld verdienen als Kommentator für eSport. Oh, da kann ich euch ein paar Storys zu erzählen.
Nicht von mir selbst, nur von Sachen, die ich die letzten über 10 Jahren YouTube mitbekommen habe. Was da teilweise geht, ist auch Scam-y. Schauen wir mal.
Also sowohl von Preisgeldern, die teilweise jahrelang nicht bezahlt werden, bis zu Castern, die nicht bezahlt werden. Also ich hab da schon über 5 Ecken Dinger mitgekriegt.
Da kannst du echt nur für den eSport Standort Deutschland den Kopf schütteln. Und international ist es wahrscheinlich auch nicht viel besser.
Wieso hat er ein Swisscom-Logo auf dem Shirt? Wahrscheinlich weil das Sponsor sind von dem Turnier oder so. Keine Ahnung.
Da ist mir ganz cool zu mein Herz einfach runtergerutscht. Im positiven Sinne erschüttert dich das, dass man so viel damit verdienen kann.
Warum? Wer ist das? Kennt man ihn? Zeig mal, wer ist das? Justin.
Neben Twitter hat er auch auf Twitch und TikTok mehr als 10.000 Follower.
Hab ja sogar ich. Bin nicht sonderlich groß. Justin. Mal gucken, ob wir den Channel von ihm sehen.
Ich würde meinen Stee eher ruhig beschreiben.
Der überlebt mit der MAP oder so. Wie kann das sein?
Aber da wusste ich natürlich noch nicht, dass es sich lohnt das Team, wie eine zusätzliche Channel für den Abend steht.
Moin, ich bin Justin, ich bin 22 Jahre alt. Ich arbeite da selbstständiger E-Sports-Kommentator. Und heute zeige ich euch, wie mein Tag so aussieht.
Also eins muss man ja sagen, die haben echt ein ganz gutes Gespür für. Die hatten noch letztens auch irgendeinen Streamer.
Und ich muss sagen, der Streamer, den sie letztens vorgestellt haben, der hat auch einen äußerst sympathischen Eindruck gemacht. Der ist mir auch gleich auf den ersten Blick sympathisch.
Okay, Moment, wir müssen ganz kurz in den Chat gucken. Questions. Hey, ich will mir einen Bewegungsmelder mit das Motor zulegen. Anschluss soll 230 Volt sein.
Warum? Also für 230 Volt fallen mir hauptsächlich Shelley-Geräte ein. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob Shelley ein Bewegungsmelder hat.
230 Volt muss es? Warum darf es nicht? Ich meine, wenn du da eine Steckdose hast, spricht ja da auch nichts dagegen, dort ein Netzteil reinzustecken, oder?
Welches OS läuft auf deinem Server bzw. was würdest du anfangen mit Home Assistant Edgar? Welches System? Also was du dir angucken kannst, ist Enjoyer.
Home Server Enjoyer kannst du dir angucken. Da steht, was ich laufen habe. So ungefähr zumindest. Und was ich im Einsatz habe, kannst du dir das Video angucken. Das kam sogar relativ gut an.
Netzteil wäre auch okay. Ich weiß es nicht. Ganz ehrlich, ich habe nur von Aquara, die Show-Me-Dinger habe ich was über Zigbee und in meinem Server habe ich einen Sea-Wave-Bewegungsmelder stehen.
Kabel-Los, Shelley-Motion, wenn die einen haben, ja vielleicht. Die Shelley-Dinger kann man eigentlich immer empfehlen, die sind okay. Die funktionieren immer ohne Cloud.
Ah gut, das ist aber anscheinend nicht zum Anschließen. Ganz ehrlich, mir fällt jetzt keiner ein, der nicht batteriebetrieben ist, wo ich schon mal was mit zu tun hätte. Nee, keine Ahnung. Kann ich dir keine empfehlen.
Ja, also ich würde dir aber auf jeden Fall Home Assistant empfehlen. Das Einzige, wo du dir überlegen musst, ist, ob du deinen Server verwenden möchtest für normales Linux-Zeug plus Home Assistant.
Oder ob du hauptsächlich Heim-Automatisierung machen willst und mit Home Assistant Addons klarkommst, weil Sachen wie AddGuard und so gibt es auch als Home Assistant Addons. Im Endeffekt sind es irgendwelche Docker-Container.
Ich habe halt Ubuntu drunter und eine Home Assistant VM da drunter laufen. So werde ich das mit Unraid auch machen, weil ich unten drunter eben noch Dinge machen will, die ich nicht unbedingt als Home Assistant Addon haben will.
Ja, das ist wirklich nice, ZigBee to MQTT.
Ich habe das damals glücklicherweise gleich genommen, weil die ZigBee-Integration noch nicht so weit war und die alte schon deprecated war. Da blieb mir nicht so viel anderes übrig.
Und da bin ich drauf hängen geblieben und seitdem finde ich das nice. Egal, aber jetzt gucken wir mal, was man als Kommentator so verdienen kann.
Kurz einen Cheat machen. Was, einen Cheat? Gegen 13 Uhr gehe ich an den Stream und wenn abends ein Turnier ist, caste ich das Turnier oder kommentiere das Turnier.
Was mich interessieren würde ist, macht er das auf seinem eigenen Channel oder wird da eingekauft, das woanders zu machen?
Weil damit steht und fällt ein bisschen, ob die dich scammen oder was heißt scammen? Ob dich irgendwelche Veranstalter für ein Apple und ein Ei kriegen oder nicht?
Ja, in der Fischung bin ich live, das alle Bescheid wissen.
Weil was ich beispielsweise aus dem Valorant Umfeld schon mitbekommen habe, nur weil es ein aktueller Spiel ist, den ich ein paar Leute kenne, die da eSport technisch aktiv sind.
Was ich aus dem Valorant Umfeld schon mitbekommen habe ist, wenn es gerade in Deutschland Turniere gibt und die nach Castern suchen, dass die sehr knauserig sind, was die Bezahlung angeht.
So nach dem Motto, wie du willst angemessen bezahlt werden? Null gibt es nicht. Wir finden genug junge anspruchslose Leute, die das umsonst oder billiger machen.
Man bekommt dann zwar nicht die richtig guten Caster, aber wir reden ja hier nicht von einem CSGO Major, sondern wir reden hier von irgendeinem deutschen Turnier, was wahrscheinlich eh nur maximal 1000 Leute gucken.
Und das ist sehr fragwürdig, was da teilweise läuft.
Deswegen, wenn das auf seinem eigenen Channel ist, dann ist das natürlich schon gleich viel besser. Wir gucken uns das gleich an, dann ist er aber auch weniger Caster-Freelancer, sondern mehr Fortnite-Influencer-Streamer mit eigenem Channel, der sich dort auf eSport spezialisiert hat. Schauen wir mal.
Dann läuft es meistens auch. Tatsächlich bin ich aufgeregt. Heute um 19 Uhr ist das FNCS Grand Final, also Fortnite-Championship-Series. Das ist das größte Turnier, was es in Europa gerade gibt, was da heute stattfindet und das kommuniziere ich heute Abend.
Kennt das jemand? Chat? Wie viele Leute gucken das? 3, 2, 1 und wir gehen rein. Und dann sind wir live. Und wenn halt nichts ist, stream ich den ganzen Tag.
Schütze ist schon da. Passi Ball ist auch da. Sehr, sehr schön.
Ja, das war offizielle Spielecast. Da dachte ich mir, die Frage ist, casten die bei sich auf dem Channel oder müssen die in Einkaufen für ihre Produktion?
Moin, Moin, Moin, Moin, Moin Jungs. Wie geht's euch? Alles gut bei euch? Der Stream ist für mich sehr wichtig, damit man eine Bindung aufbaut mit den Zuschauern, die auch hinter dem Cast reinschauen könnten.
Eventuell, dass sie dich auch ein bisschen besser kennen als nur deine professionelle Seite, nur deine Arbeitseite, sag ich mal. Lohnt sich das bei mir, ihr wisst ja schon Bescheid.
Das heißt, wir machen aber alles ganz normal, so wie immer. Wir spielen unsere Zone Wars, als ob nichts wäre. Das ist sehr gut. Ihr könnt ab jetzt theoretisch in mein Lobby reingehen gleich.
Manchmal merkt man das schon. Das ist bei ihm auf dem Channel auf jeden Fall. Das ist Fortnite, Alter. Da bist du mit 22 schon alt. Was soll ich denn sagen mit 37, Alter?
Ich sitze hier vorm Rechner. Erzähl was mit 37 Jahren. Poggers, Cringe, Lull. Da komme ich mir doppelt so alt vor, wenn ich höre, dass ein Fortnite mit 22 schon alt ist, Mann.
Klappt das ganz gut, ja. Die meisten sind so ungefähr 15. Ja, gut. Typisches Fortnite-Publikum. Die meisten sind wirklich so über 20. Das kommt fast gar nicht vor.
Ich könnte mal kurz in den Chat reinfragen, wie alt alle sind. Vielleicht kriegen wir da instant einen Feedback. Also die meisten sind wirklich auch noch sehr jung.
Im Vergleich zu mir sind das alles jung und hübsch. Die haben noch ihre besten Tage vor sich. Connie ist 30. Connie ist der Manager von meiner Agentur. Also Grüße gehen raus.
Ich bin bei meiner Agentur in der Vertrag und die kann natürlich noch mal besser mir neue Kunden vermitteln, als ich das selber könnte. Aber das ist eigentlich so üblich, dass du gemacht hast.
Das ist tatsächlich sinnig. Das habe ich auch gemerkt, dass es schwierig ist, sich selbst um den ganzen Kram zu kümmern.
Weil gerade die ganzen Marketing-Stonks-Leute, die versuchen zwar immer nett zu sein, aber die versuchen dich gleichermaßen eigentlich immer zu scammen.
Dass du die Sachen für viel billiger machst, als es eigentlich kosten würde. Weil umso billiger du das machst, umso mehr bleibt direkt für die Vermittler übrig.
Als Kommentator oder wie auch immer, als Social-Media-Influencer immer so eine Agentur hast, die sich dann so ein bisschen vertritt auch.
Aber wenn ich heute nicht so gut bin, kann ich einfach sagen, dass du die Maus und das Keyboard und die 9 noch. Ich muss mich darauf eingewöhnen.
Also ich habe auch durch meine Agentur da relativ guten Draht zur Logik nicht bekommen.
Ich meine, die greifen natürlich auch was ab, aber trotzdem lohnt sich das immer noch.
Da bekomme ich auch.
Es gibt eh so ein paar doofe Sprüche, die sich etabliert haben im Influencer-Marketing-Bereich.
Also so als Tipp für euch, wenn ihr rüberkommen wollt, dass ihr voll Ahnung habt, ist, wenn ihr eine Mail bekommt so nach dem Motto, wir suchen Leute für unsere Kampagne XY,
dann fragt ihr nicht so nach dem Motto, ja ok, was soll ich denn alles machen?
Nee, nee, ihr müsst fragen, was sind die? Und jetzt kommt, obacht, was sind die Deliverables, müsst ihr fragen.
Und wenn ihr fragt, was sind die Deliverables, da wissen die sofort, der weiß, wovon er spricht.
Es gibt so ein paar Basswörter irgendwie, so bescheuert das klingt, wo dieses ganze Marketing Zeug sich kommuniziert untereinander.
Deliverables, Deliverables musst du sagen, dann wissen die, du bist vom Fach, du kennst dich aus.
Ist kein Witz, ist wirklich so.
Ich habe auch immer alles, was ich irgendwie brauche, alles, was hinter mir steht, da sind die an Zimmer.
Jemand da schreibt, ich weiß es auch nicht, Deliverables, so, Leistung.
Das ändert sich auch ab und zu mal. Ja, ich meine, ich mache den Scheiß seit 2010.
Damals gab es nicht mal das Wort Influencer.
Das kam erst ein paar Jahre später auf.
Deliverables ist erst, wo mir das so untergekommen ist, sagen wir so die letzten drei, vier Jahre vielleicht.
Es ändert sich auch immer ein bisschen.
Was sind die Key Deliverables, sowas kannst du fragen, dann wissen die Bescheid, Stonks, genau.
Mäuse und so, nicht bezahlt.
Da war so Monitor und PC, das habe ich natürlich selber gekauft.
Ja, man checkt das gleich, dass heute das FNCS-Finale ist, weil das irgendwie so schnell jetzt auch alles ging.
Aber ich glaube, wenn heute Abend das Game losgeht, die erste Runde von 12, ich glaube, dann weiß jeder Bescheid.
Dann wird es aufregend. Beim Fußball gibt es ja auch so Leute, so Kommentatoren, die sind einfach zu schlecht gewesen, um zu spielen.
Deswegen kommentieren sie einfach jetzt so, das ist bei mir das Gleiche.
Ich bin einfach jetzt Kommentator, weil ich einfach zu schlecht bin zum Spiel.
Ich kann nichts machen, ich bin tot.
Ich kommentiere eSports hauptberuflich seit circa April letzten Jahres.
Das ist ja nicht so, er spielt wahrscheinlich trotzdem besser als 95% der Leute.
April 2021, es war am Anfang erstmal...
Mods, Mod-Check, wir brauchen Leute, die Leute bannen.
Keine Mods da, man muss das selbst machen.
Wo sind die alle, sind die noch da?
Wo sind die alle, sind die noch am Schlafen?
So, weg.
Ziemlich ungewohnt, so, wie soll ich sagen, so komplett von jetzt auf gleich so erfolgreich zu sein.
Wir müssen uns langsam vorbereiten auf das Interview mit Reason gleich.
Das Ganze wird auch dann morgen auf TikTok komplett schon heute Abend.
Ich weiß noch nicht ganz, wann ich es hochladen werde.
Ab vorn eigentlich letztens das Bauen entfernen? Ja ne, wohl nur im Quickplay und auch nur für diese Season irgendwie.
Heute und morgen FNCS Grand Final auf dem Mindset, die TV-Kanal auf Twitch. Bis am Abend, haut rein und schaut.
So, der Stream ist aus. 73 Zuschauer im Durchschnitt, das ist für mich sehr gut.
Chat, wir haben mehr.
Die sind schon am Start heute Abend, die meisten wissen eh Bescheid.
Soll ich auch krasser Fortnite-Influencer werden?
Da haben schon ein paar geschrieben, dass sie dabei sind heute Abend.
Nein, Fortnite ist echt was, das ist absolut nicht meins.
Was steht ihr jetzt an?
Interview mit Reason. Er hat zigtausend Euro mit Fortnite bis jetzt gewonnen.
Ich glaube es waren so 300-400.000 Euro, die er da mitgenommen hat bis heute.
Er ist noch relativ jung, ich will nichts falsch sagen, ich glaube so 15 gerade.
Alter, die Fortnite-Community-Mann, das sind alles irgendwelche Kinners.
Also Fortnite ist wirklich so ein inbegriffter Super-Community-Mann.
Nicht, dass es schlimm wäre. Fällt mir halt nur immer wieder auf, wie alt ich eigentlich mittlerweile bin.
Die Szene so gut zu kennen wie kein anderer, nicht nur den Zuschauern hat die Profis so.
Kontakte sind da bestimmt alles.
Das heißt, jetzt können wir eigentlich uns mal ransetzen. Das Interview ist noch wahnsinnig wichtig für mich und auch für meine Arbeit, für das Turnier heute Abend.
Heute Abend gibt es einfach auch eineinhalb Millionen, also eineinhalb Millionen sind im Kreisbrul.
Und das macht ja auch mit den Menschen viel, der dahinter steckt, der Spieler.
Ich möchte auch mal ein bisschen rauskitzeln, wie fühlt er sich gerade, was denkt er gerade darüber, ist er vielleicht nervös, wie war seine Vorbereitung.
Das heißt, ich kann im Stream, im Cast, beim Kommentieren viel erzählen, was die normalen Zuschauer nicht wissen.
Aber das ist ja auch genau mein Job. Hallo? Danny?
Hallo? Ah, okay, okay.
Wie ist denn so jetzt, paar Stunden vor dem Grand Final, so deine Aufregung?
Bist du so ein bisschen am Zittern schon oder wie fühlst du dich jetzt gerade?
Nö, ich fühle mich perfekt. Ich habe zwar noch nichts gegessen, habe gerade eine Runde CSGO gespielt, aber eigentlich fühle ich mich perfekt bis jetzt.
Ich war nur laufen und habe geduscht bis jetzt.
Ich hoffe natürlich, dass du dieses Wochenende das Ding gewinnen kannst. In dem Sinne, hau rein.
Was hast du zufällig mitbekommen, dass Luis Rossmann aus Protest seinen Twitch-Channel geläuscht hat? Nee, habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Hi Lenny, viel Spaß hier, Tschütze.
Info, die für mich relevant ist, ist, dass er früher immer sehr nervös war, er hat früher immer sehr viel gezittert und so.
Da meint der Ganze mir, er ist gar nicht aufgeregt, er fühlt sich perfekt vorbereitet. Das ist schon so eine Info, die ist für mich auch gut.
Vielleicht auch ein bisschen Selbstbeholung, oder?
Weil ich mit ihm schon seit längerem zusammenarbeitet, auch so ein bisschen befreundet bin.
In meiner Freizeit gehe ich ganz gerne auch Drohnen fliegen. Da habe ich so was für mich entdeckt, dass ich einfach mal ganz kurz mich fühlen kann wie ein Vogel.
Und das mache ich schon ganz gerne, dass man sich einfach ins Auto mit reinsetzt und einfach neben dem Auto herfliegt.
Wie alle einfach ein geileres Auto haben als ich, ja?
Sehr cool, ja.
Wobei, dafür habe ich bin ab schon das agilste Auto.
Das ist mein schöner Firmwarenwagen, richtig. Ich bin schon sehr oft Langstrecken gefahren nach Stuttgart oder in die Schweiz zum Arbeiten.
Das ist auch nicht schwer. Was soll das heißen?
Was soll das heißen? Das ist nicht schwer.
Auch ein Firmauto zu haben. Mein größter Luxus auf meinem Auto. Ich bin bis da.
Moment.
2001. Grün.
Das ist grün. Ja.
Also, wenn Sie sich fragen, was ich für ein Auto habe.
Ja, es ist wirklich nicht schwer, ein geileres Auto zu haben. Das stimmt schon.
Aber so selten wie ich Auto fahre, ist das gar nicht verkehrt.
Damit erkennt man dich. Das stimmt wohl. So viele grüne Opel Agilas wird es wahrscheinlich in Haarau nicht geben.
Egal, weiter.
Ato, immer Autos gefahren, die nicht so viel gekostet haben, weil ich einfach da nicht viel Geld ausgeben wollte.
Jetzt fahren wir erstmal nach Steinhude.
Dort ist so der beste Spot, um da irgendwie ein paar coole Drohnenaufnahmen zu machen.
Los geht's. Starten oder bereit zu machen.
So, jetzt sind wir entspannt.
Das ist ja auch geil, Alter.
Man kann quasi im warmen Auto hocken mit dem Headset auf und einen Drohnen fliegen. Das ist doch Pock, oder?
Genau das Richtige zum Ausgleich vor dem Rechner sitzen. Die Drohne sieht...
Ach, die fahren da jetzt. Der eine fährt und die andere... Ja, das ist ja mal nice.
Der eine fährt im Auto und der andere macht Drohnenstells. Das ist eigentlich mal richtig nice.
Da hätte ich auch Bock drauf. Das macht bestimmt Spaß.
Das ist gut. Nice. Das macht Spaß.
Das sieht einfach aus wie so ein Videospiel, oder wie wenn man als Vogel irgendwo lang fliegt.
Das ist cool. Das sieht erstmal ultra cool. Du siehst natürlich die Welt von einem anderen Winkel.
Sekunde. Toss Musik. Toss Musik. Toss, Toss, Toss.
Ich muss Sounds machen, dass es nicht tost. Ich muss hören, wenn es fertig ist, wenn er anfängt.
Ich bin ready. Er ist ready. Kann losgehen. Wir sind auch ready.
Jetzt geht es an die weitere Vorbereitung und dann läuft das Ganze.
So, ich höre euch wieder. Ich bin beim Kommentieren nicht alleine.
Warum man die Brille braucht und nicht mit dem Display?
Ich gehe einfach mal davon aus, weil das mehr immersive ist, wenn du die Brille aufhast.
Wunderbare Kollegen von mir, Christiane Torres und Pistolenhendri.
Wir kommentieren schon seit etwas längerer Zeit zusammen.
Pistolenhendri. Und das klappt auch in diesem Dreiergespann sehr gut.
Wir starten 18.40 Uhr, dann geht die Lochschau los, dann willkommen, Overview.
Pistolenhendri ist ein mega geiler Name.
Dann leitet am besten einer von uns über ins Video und dann immer so weiter.
Ich habe damit ja schon als Kind angefangen. Auf einem Bolzplatz habe ich meine Freunde kommentiert beim Spielen.
Es ist eine Weltpremiere.
Davon gibt es auch ein paar lustige Videos.
Weltpremiere. Der könnte die nächste Xbox-Präsentation machen.
Da ist auch immer alles Worldpremiere.
Unabhängig davon, ob es überhaupt nicht Premiere ist oder nicht.
Boah, da ist 2-0 von Melvin Linke, der Idiot, kommt zur Kamera.
Das ist noch für eine kleine Challenge auch zu haben.
Ja.
Was ist das?
Als du mir einen Umstand gegeben hast, war ich erst mal ein bisschen verwirrt.
Und dachte ich ganz kurz, was ist das denn?
Bau diese Wörter beim Kommentieren ein.
Zahltag lohnt sich das in Hackschnitzel.
Also bei Hackschnitzel war ich ein bisschen überfordert.
Ach Quatsch.
Hackschnitzel kriegst du auch irgendwie eingebaut.
Was weiß ich, irgendwie, der hat ihn zerstört.
Bam, bam, Hackschnitzel, keine Ahnung.
Da fällt ihm schon was ein.
Da dachte ich, wie kommt man darauf?
Schaffst du das, ohne dass es jemand merkt?
Ich schaff das. Das merkt niemand.
Nehme ich an. Ich schaff das.
Herzlich willkommen alle, die jetzt hier am Start sind.
FNCS Viewing Party.
Kyle Justin ist natürlich bei sich zu Hause mit einem neuen Haarschnitt.
Der hat sich nicht loppen lassen.
Hat sich sogar noch die Haare extra für heute geschnitten.
Damit wir heute einfach ready sein.
Ich glaube, heute erwartet uns sehr, sehr viel.
Und die erste Frage, die ich erst mal habe,
lohnt sich das Ganze mit dem Haarschnitt jetzt?
Ich weiß es nicht ganz, aber ich glaube,
der Haarschnitt ist auf jeden Fall mega fresh.
Kommt gut rüber, glaube ich.
Und ich glaube auch heute, Henry, heute ist der Zahltag.
Heute geht es um alles. Heute kommt es darauf an, wer plays wo?
Sechs Games heute, sechs Games morgen.
Das heißt, uns wird sehr, sehr viel erwarten an diesem Wochenende.
Und ich würde sagen, wir können uns auf einiges gefasst machen.
Ich habe dann die Challenge gecheckt
und dann auch relativ schnell, glaube ich, umgesetzt.
Habe ich eigentlich alles gesagt?
Ich bin ready, ja.
Ich bin voll ready und ich bin auch drauf.
Natürlich, wenn du irgendwie neu anfängst,
dann hast du irgendwie mal so eine Gage von 200, 300 Euro.
Aber mittlerweile ist mir so,
das beläuft sich so zwischen 500 und 700 Euro pro Abend, ja.
Man muss halt mal sagen,
je nachdem, wie lang diese Casts sind,
kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten, ob das super krass viel ist, ne?
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie lange diese Turniere gehen,
aber gehen wir mal von aus, dass da irgendwie so ein Cast,
was weiß ich, dass der, was weiß ich, 15 Stunden ist oder so,
das ist jetzt nicht so krass.
Okay, die ist nur in Public, okay, die ist nur in Public.
Ich meine, man kann natürlich trotzdem super von Leben,
wenn das mehrfach pro Woche ist oder so, kein Ding.
Noch eine ganz krasse, sie holen den Kill!
Wer macht das auch so stark?
Reez ist jetzt hier, auch relativ schnell,
dann holt jetzt hier den Kill, rächt sich quasi für Reezen dort.
Die HP muss er bekommen.
Es ist halt mal so, dass irgendwie einmal richtig viel ist.
Das sind irgendwie zwei richtig große Turniere,
drei richtig große Turniere, was mal einmal nicht sein kann.
Also, in der Regel sind das dann 4.000 Euro im Monat circa,
aber es gab auch immer Monats, da waren es irgendwie 15.000 Euro.
Also, es gibt halt wieder das externe und das normale.
Hat er da die Möglichkeit, er probiert es mit dem Sway,
ein paar HP bekommt er dazu, jetzt eventuell das Medkit ansetzen,
das schafft er aber auch nicht.
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung, was so normale, wie soll ich sagen,
Gehälter für Caster sind, aber ich glaube tatsächlich,
dass 600 Euro da auf der niedrigeren Seite sind
für so einen Contract, für so ein Turnier,
eingekauft für ein Turnier.
Gut, das kannst du nicht so einfach googeln.
Ich kann das aber zumindest damit vergleichen,
was du als halbwegs großer YouTube-Channel für Videos bekommst,
beziehungsweise für Sponsored Streams.
Und Sponsored Streams, selbst bei meiner Größe,
was ja nun wirklich nicht groß ist, im Vergleich zu anderen auf Twitch,
selbst Sponsored Streams bei mir, die gehen dann, sagen wir mal,
zwei, zweieinhalb Stunden vielleicht.
Und das ist mehr als das, was es für einen Abend gibt.
Und die sitzen bestimmt länger dabei.
Natürlich muss man dazu sagen, ich mache auch kaum Sponsored Streams.
Und dementsprechend ist es jetzt nicht so, als wäre das bei mir
jeden Abend als Einnahmequelle zu verbuchen.
Aber deswegen bin ich der Meinung, 600 klingt jetzt erst mal krass,
aber ich glaube, an Gehältern ist es gar nicht so viel.
Informatisch studieren, so schwer ist es wirklich.
Mal vielleicht danach gucken.
Also, er muss eigentlich auf ihrem Skin, er muss jetzt auf dem Kiel gehen, Henry.
Er hat gar keine andere Chance. Er holt einen, er nocht jetzt hier links.
Wichtig, 10 AP nur noch, dann ist es low.
Das ist halt Fortnite eSport, du siehst im Prinzip die Leute gegen eine Wand gucken und bauen
und ab und zu ist die Wand kaputt und das Shotgun dich einer kaputt.
Nein, er geht da runter.
Oder was auch immer es ist. Er geht da runter.
Also das ist das eigentliche, was ich von Fortnite eSport bisher gesehen habe, ist,
Leute, was weiß ich, 15 Leute in der Endzone, alle irgendwie 30 Kilometer hohe Türme
und jeder versucht, den anderen zu outbilden und ab und zu ist da mal eine Wand kaputt
und dann schießt dann einer durch und One-Shotted den mit der Shotgun
und dann wird weitergebildet, wie verrückt.
Also ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, das, was ich bisher gesehen habe von Fortnite eSport,
ist nicht so die Begeisterung bei mir da gewesen.
Drücken wir das mal so aus. Dabei bin ich ansonsten relativ aufgeschlossen, was das angeht.
Ich habe lange wirklich viel CSGO geguckt, jetzt in den letzten Jahren auch weniger.
Overwatch habe ich ja selbst ziemlich lange aktiv gespielt, semi, semi gut.
Das Einzige, das Beste, was wir mal geschafft haben, ist, dass wir irgendwie Zweiter waren.
Wir haben den deutschen ESL-Weekly-Cup mal gewonnen und irgendwie waren wir Zweiter bei irgendeinem anderen ESL-Ding.
Also ganz knicken. Aber Fortnite habe ich wirklich viel gespielt
und habe dementsprechend auch viel eSport geguckt drumherum, was das angeht.
Aber Fortnite ist wirklich, ich mein's, sowohl vom Spiel her als auch vom Gucken her.
StarCraft habe ich auch mega gerne geguckt.
Ich bin ganz ehrlich, da ist mir ganz kurz mein Herz einfach runtergerutscht in Bereiche, da soll es nicht sein.
Hackschnitzel. Sie haben es gemacht, haben jetzt hier genug Loot. Sie haben Spider-Man-Handschuhe.
Oder ein Hackschnitzel.
Er muss Hackschnitzel noch einbauen.
Aber sehen wir uns jetzt den nächsten Kill. Joe wird jetzt hier geholt von Thomas.
Also wahnsinnig stark gemacht. Den Kill gerochen und auch Dreck geholt.
Hackschnitzel. Das war dann quasi wie so ein Hackschnitzel.
Das hätte man aber besser verpacken können.
Geil.
Das hätte man irgendwie ein bisschen besser verpacken können.
Was weiß ich. Da hat es ihn gegeben, es hat richtig geklatscht oder so was.
So richtig Hackschnitzel. Keine Ahnung. Irgendwie sowas.
Aber er hat es hingekriegt.
Okay, bis morgen. Haut rein.
Wo wir es gerade von Overwatch haben. Moin Eax.
Eax, wie sieht es aus?
Wollen wir uns Ende des nächsten, wollen wir uns nächsten Monat mal eine Runde Overwatch 2 Beta geben und uns aufregen?
Und aninstallen?
Der Eax war damals unser DPS, einer unserer DPS Mainz.
Weiß ich, wann ist das?
Wann startet das? Irgendwann Ende April, glaube ich. Die Overwatch 2 Beta.
Und tschüss.
Okay, hat jemand verfolgt? Wie lange das jetzt ging, das Turnier?
Wie lange war das?
Wie lange war er am Start? Vier Stunden oder so, ne?
Am Anfang war ich ein bisschen nervös, weil die Kamera hier noch dabei war oder wie auch immer, aber am Ende war es dann gut.
Ja, ich habe zwischendurch gesagt, dass ReaZen sich sehr viel confidenter fühlt, also nicht mehr so nervös ist.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das Coole ist, da kann er mit 600 Euro schon gut davon leben.
Das wird ja im Prinzip, umso bekannter er wird, umso mehr wird das ja und umso besser wird das was.
Vor allem umso mehr in einer Position ist, wo die Leute ihn halt auch haben wollen, dass die Turniere sagen können, hier Broadcast Talent, weiß gar nicht wie sein Nickname ist, jetzt weiß ich auch nicht, Justin, wo man das gesehen hat, wie kein Overwatch Eax.
Da wird es natürlich immer mehr werden. Das wird sich für ihn wahrscheinlich nur positiv entwickeln.
Einzige Sache, die einem natürlichen Strich durch die Rechnung machen könnte, ist, wenn Fortnite irgendwie jetzt in der Bedeutungslosigkeit verschwinden sollte, aber danach sieht es ja bei Fortnite nicht aus.
Ich meine, Fortnite ist nicht mehr das ultra Hype-Ding, wo du quasi überall zugeschissen wirst mit an jeder Ecke und überall Millionen von Views abgreifst, aber es ist immer noch groß.
Und gerade die Generation Fortnite, die wird Fortnite auch noch eine Weile treu bleiben.
Ich glaube, die ersten beiden Runden waren perfekt. Allgemein hat man schon gemerkt, dass er nicht mehr so nervös war und das konnte ich schon so irgendwo unterbringen und mitteilen, dass es auch für ihn besser liefern kann.
Das ist bestimmt Tossmusik. Das ist Toss, Toss, Toss, alles Tossmusik, Tossmusik.
Tossmusik, Tossmusik. Ja, Steuerberater muss sein, bei sowas hast du keine Chance.
Immer noch, ja.
Das ist ja das, was ich liebe, also ich liebe diesen Job hier, ich liebe das Spiel.
200 Euro Miete, ich denke mal davon, ich gehe mal davon aus, das ist bei ihm daheim irgendwo, oder?
Er wird wahrscheinlich einfach daheim ein bisschen, wie soll man sagen, Aufwand bezahlen. Wahrscheinlich ist das daheim noch. Würde ich auch machen.
Das Spiel, seit ich klein bin, auch spiele und dass ich jetzt das kommentieren darf, ist natürlich noch viel größer für mich. Vielen Dank fürs Zusehen, ich hoffe, das Video hat euch gefallen.
Das Beste, was du machen kannst, das Beste, was du in der Situation machen kannst, daheim wohnen bleiben.
Hier geht es nun zu weiteren Videos, hier ist mein Lieblingsfilm mit dem Streamer und hier geht es zu einem weiteren Video von Lohnt-sich-das, lasst auch gerne euer Feedback in den Kommentaren da.
Der war auch echt sympathisch, der Kalle, den haben wir letztens geguckt.
Ich hoffe, euch das Video gefallen, würde mich interessieren.
Und tschau tschau, bye bye, feiert noch schön Leute. Peace.
Also, das ist das, das, das, das, das größte, das größte Fremdschemen war mal, als ich zum Südbahnhof gelaufen bin und irgendwie so eine Gruppe 12-, 13-Jähriger vor die Straßenbahn gesprungen, also die hielt da, die sind nicht in die Fahrtrichtung der Straßenbahn gesprungen, die sind am Südbahnhof vor die Straßenbahn gehüpft und haben den Loser Dance vor dem Fahrerhäuschen gemacht.
Stellt euch das mal vor, so eine Gruppe halbstarger 12-, 13-Jähriger machen den Loser Dance vom Fahrerhäuschen der Straßenbahn, das war so, allein schon das Zuschauen, allein der Anblick dessen hat mich innerlich so hardcore Fremdschemen lassen, wie ich das selten erlebt hab.
Der Loser Dance.
Das da, das ist der Loser Dance.
Und so, so standen da halt 12-, 13-Jährige vor dem Fahrerhäuschen in der Straßenbahn und haben den Loser Dance gemacht.
Cringe, Alter, richtig hart, richtig, eines der härtesten Cringe Momente, die ich je erlebt habe.
Schon Erfahrungen mit Super Base gemacht? Nee, ich weiß, dass das als Alternative zu Fire Base bisschen gehandelt wird. Leute, ich muss mal ganz schnell was zu trinken holen.
Cringe, Alter, richtig hart.
Wieder am Start. Was mit dem M-Core ist, ja, M-Core's Kanal wurde gehackt, aber der versucht den auch gerade wieder zu bekommen.
Ja, M-Core YouTube. Ja, guckt mal. M-Core's Channel wurde gehackt, feelsBadMan.
Macht jetzt, macht jetzt Werbung für irgendwelchen Crypto-Shit-Scams.
Ja.
Er wollte sich halt beruflich um... Nein, nein, der Account wurde gehackt, das weiß ich aus erster Hand, also die sind da gerade dabei.
Ich muss auch kurz lüften, hier ist es mega warm. Hast du einen Tipp für eine gute mechanische Tastatur?
Ja, hab ich, aus erster Hand, und zwar ich verwende auf der Arbeit seit vier Jahren oder so mittlerweile schon eine Ducky One Skyline mit NumBlock.
Das Teil. Das finde ich richtig nice. Und es hat super, das kann man an der Stelle auch mal elo, hast du die vom Geschäft bekommen? Nein, die habe ich selbst gekauft.
Es hat super haltbare, ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie man das nennt, Beschriftung? Beschichtung? Welche Switches, das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ich habe das auch wahrscheinlich Standard. Was sind Standard? Die braunen?
Ja, zumindest die haben super krasse Beschichtung, also die sind wirklich mega robust. Ich habe hier aktuell von Logitech daheim eine, das habe ich hauptsächlich wegen der Logitech Software und ein bisschen RGB-Stells.
Da geht auf der rechten Shift-Taste beispielsweise unten, ist es schon ein bisschen weniger gut sichtbar.
Durch Kratzer oder so. Und hier ist gar nichts. Also das ist wirklich qualitativ, ist wirklich super das Teil. Du kannst theoretisch Makros programmieren damit.
Das hat hinten einen Schalter, aber das ist nicht komfortabel. Es gibt halt auch keine Treiber und Software dafür.
Also die finde ich gut, die kann ich empfehlen. Es gibt bestimmt noch massig andere gute mechanische Tastaturen, aber die habe ich nicht ausprobiert.
Die hier habe ich ausprobiert, die verwende ich den Vorgänger auch schon jahrelang wunderbar. Kann man sich wirklich nicht drüber beschweren.
Ja seht ihr Leute, allein schon hier im Chat sieht man, das sind wieder 30.000 verschiedene Sachen, die es gibt an Tastaturen. Eine gescheite Wireless-Mechanik.
Nö. Ich muss sagen, Tastatur habe ich am Kabel, meine Maus ist Wireless. Wireless-Tastatur? Weiß nicht. Weil Tastaturen bewegst du ja selten.
Maus ja schon eher, da ist Kabel nervig. Dachte ja auch die ganze Zeit, dass nur kabelgebundene Mäuse das einzig wahre sind. Aber seitdem ich mir hier dieses Kit, dieses Pro Wireless Logitech Kit gekauft habe mit dem Mauspad, was die Maus auflädt, muss ich sagen, ich will eigentlich nichts anderes mehr haben.
Nur, was cool wäre, wenn das ein bisschen größer noch wäre. Also ich habe hier dieses, oh, Wireless Pad, Charging Pad, dieses Pad da. Es wäre cool, wenn es das Pad noch in größer gäbe.
Für mich ist das gerade ausreichend und ich bin jetzt nicht der ultra Low-Sense-Spieler, aber wenn ich ein bisschen mehr Low-Sense spielen wollen würde, noch mehr, also in die Richtung, wie das andere machen, dann bräuchte ich das in vielleicht mal, sag mal mal, 10 cm vielleicht noch mal größer.
Also ich spiele ja meistens mit ungefähr von da bis da 360° Drehung in so ziemlich allen Spielen. Das ist nicht sonderlich Low, das ist jetzt nicht High, das ist aber auch nicht, das ist nicht CSGO Competitive Sense.
CSGO Competitive Sense ist ja im Prinzip einmal über den Schreibtisch gefahren, eine halbe Umdrehung übertrieben gesagt. Die spielen ja alle ultra, ultra Low, aber bei CS ist es beispielsweise auch was anderes, wie Battlefield oder so.
Battlefield bist du viel mobiler, musst viel mehr rumdrehen, in CS weißt du ja meistens wo du hingehen musst, aber sag mal so, wenn man sowas verwenden will für Low-Sense Sachen, dann ist es ein bisschen klein. Also da hätte ich mir gewünscht, dass es das in groß gibt.
Avira möchte mich wieder scammen auf dem zweiten Rechner, warum habe ich diesen Müll da überhaupt noch drauf? Gehst du fort?
So, was haben wir sonst noch schönes hier? Informatik studieren, so schwer ist es wirklich. Alpha Uni.
Home Automation Ideas. What meeting sounds like Twitter? Day in the life of an Amazon Software Engineer. Meint ihr, der arbeitet was oder das ist wieder so ein typisches Video?
Wir stehen auf, dann machen wir Fitness, dann gehen wir einen Snack crabben, dann gehen wir mieten, dann gehen wir noch einen Snack crabben, dann gehen wir Tischkicker spielen, dann gehen wir noch einen Snack crabben, dann gehen wir Mittagessen in die Kantine, dann programmieren wir vielleicht mal was, dann machen wir wieder Team Meeting und dann gehen wir was auch immer. Meint ihr, das ist was realistisches? Gucken wir mal, acht Minuten halten wir aus.
Und danach, weil ihr es seid, gucken wir uns auch noch Informatik studieren an. Scheint ja einige zu interessieren. Mach eine Prediction, ich gehe davon aus, du hast Meditation und Mindset Training vergessen.
Jaja und natürlich Daily Performance Analyse mit dem Chef, wie das bei Amazon ja wohl so sein muss. Ach ne, aber keine Prediction auf Twitch. Ich gehe davon aus, es ist realistisch. Ich gehe davon aus, es ist realistisch, weil es ist kein Werbevideo in dem Sinn.
Bücher zur Persönlichkeitsentwicklung, ja. Also am merkwürdigsten war immer noch das Video, wo wir mal geguckt haben, wo auch einer gezeigt hat irgendwie das Leben eines Informatikers oder so.
Das könnte auch bei was verdient eigentlich gewesen sein, wo man sich echt gefragt hat, was macht der eigentlich den ganzen Tag?
Ist das TOS Musik? Aua, ua, ua, ua, ua, ua. Wisst ihr, bei Amazon arbeiten ja Leute, die technisch Ahnung haben. Wisst ihr, was ich mich da immer frage? Warum haben die alle diese komischen DX Racer Stühle?
Ich meine, meine Erfahrung damit mag vielleicht outdated sein, weil ich hatte den DX Racer vor sieben Jahren und der Stuhl war Müll. Und am Ende ist er noch auseinandergebrochen.
Also wackelig war er von Anfang an und am Ende ist sogar noch die Armlehne aus dem Rahmen rausgebrochen. Also ich würde mir nie wieder einen DX Racer kaufen. Ich kaufe mir eh keinen anderen Stuhl mehr, ich bin mit dem hier mega zufrieden jetzt.
Aua, ua, ua, ua. Check Social Media, genau. Das mache ich, das mache ich aber morgens auch immer. Also ich, ich, ähm, wache meistens auf so 7.30 Uhr oder so.
So irgendwie oder 7.00, 7.15 Uhr oder so was. Und dann mache ich meistens noch, auf dem Handy gucke ich mal ganz kurz Twitter, YouTube ein bisschen rum. Dann starte ich den Rechner und um keine Zeit zu verlieren, noch während mein Rechner bootet, nehme ich mein Handy und schreibe im Teams Home Office Start.
Wir haben so einen, wir haben so einen Channel, danach rechnen wir auch die Zeit ab. Und das heißt, sobald ich auf den Power Knopf des Rechners drücke oder eigentlich schon, sobald ich quasi die Tür des Arbeitszimmers betrete im Endeffekt schon.
Also das ist wirklich Sekundenoptimiert, wird in den Teams Kanal reingeschrieben, Home Office Start. Dann wird der Rechner erstmal eingeschaltet, eingeloggt und gut ist.
Ich, ich mache mein Bett nicht. Es liegt oftmals, oftmals noch abends da. Also nicht immer, was heißt nicht, nicht ist falsch. Ich habe es so oft, dass es abends einfach immer noch da liegt, dann lüfte ich das mal kurz aus, aber zu faul.
Nicht mal automatisiert, das stimmt.
Mein Stuhl, mein Stuhl ist das Ding hier, Seeldusmister24. Der da. Der da. Der Stuhl, genau. Sieht unspektakulär aus, ist aber ein richtig geiler Stuhl.
Du kannst die Lehnen links, rechts, vorne, hinten, oben, unten verstellen. Du kannst den Abstand zwischen Pobbes und Rückenlehne verstellen. Du kannst einstellen, wie hart und weich die Rückenlehne nachgibt oder gar nicht.
Du kannst das Ding Höhen verstellen. Du kannst einstellen, wie geneigt ist dein Unterteil oder wie gerade, wie geneigt ist dein Unterteil. Du kannst, also vom Stuhl. Du kannst alles einstellen.
Du kannst alles einstellen. Das Ding ist mit Abstand. Außerdem sind die Polster bequem und die Armlehnen sind schön groß und vor allem schön stabil.
Da kannst du auch mal raging. Also das ist wirklich, da geht nichts kaputt. Das ist gummiert, aber so, dass man auch noch genug drüber rutscht. Also das ist wirklich, also für mich ist es mit Abstand der beste Stuhl, den ich je hatte.
Und auch würde ich jedem Gaming-Chair vorziehen. Ich hatte ja davor einen. Kaufen würde ich das Ding nicht unbedingt, weil das viel zu teuer ist. Es sei denn, man bekommt es im Angebot.
Ja, krasse. Ach so, das kannst du dir aussuchen. Den gibt es mit Nackenlehne so und den gibt es mit Nackenlehne. Es gibt zwei verschiedene Nackenlehnen. Kann man sogar bestücken, wie man lustig ist.
Und so. Es gibt quasi eher Kopfstütze und eher Nackenlehne. Ich habe den da. Ich habe den da und hier obendran habe ich noch ein übrig gebliebenes DX Racer Kissen, was bei meinem alten DX Racer dabei war. Das ist das einzige, teilweise davon, dass es noch ein bisschen weiter nach vorne geht.
Nee, Kopfstütze ist nicht useless. Mit dem Kissen dran ist es richtig gut. Max Gewicht, ich glaube 250 Kilo oder so. Also, um es mal so zu sagen, es reicht, ja. Ach nee, hier 200 Kilo, 200 Kilo.
Also, um es mal so zu sagen, es reicht, ja. Ach nee, hier 200 Kilo, 200 Kilo. Es sollte, es sollte, es sollte reichen, ja. Und ja, die Kohle lohnt sich, wenn man viel vor dem Rechner hockt.
Ich habe abgenommen, Leute. Seitdem ich hier seit Wochen lang Entzündung im Hals habe und ich ja immer noch die Vermutung habe, dass es ein bisschen an Sodbrennen liegt, ich esse weniger und ich futter nicht mehr so viel fettiges Zeug und das bringt was.
Und ich habe jetzt schon 5 Kilo abgenommen. Einfach durch weniger Essen. Wie kann es nur sein, dass es einfach funktioniert? Weniger Essen gleich abnehmen. Easy.
Ich dachte, man braucht ja irgendwie so eine krasse Intervallfasten App. Ohne die geht das gar nicht. Ja, also den habe ich. Und das Problem, das einzige Problem bei dem Stuhl ist,
der ist ein bisschen teuer. Deswegen kann ich es auch keinem empfehlen, sich den zu kaufen. Es sei denn, ihr verbringt wirklich sehr, sehr viele Stunden vor dem PC an jedem Tag und ihr wollt was richtig bequemes haben.
Also wenn ihr Geld damit verdient, am PC zu sitzen, dann lohnt sich das. Nachdem ich quasi doppelt, dreifach, wenn du so willst, Geld mit am PC sitzen verdiene, sowohl auf der Arbeit, sowohl mit Twitch als auch mit YouTube und nicht noch just for fun, auch Sachen Spiele ohne Geld zu verdienen, ist natürlich für mich optimal.
Lohnen sich auch günstigere Stühle, klar. Es lohnt sich im Prinzip alles, was dich angenehmer und entspannter vor dem Rechner sitzen lässt.
Und auch wenn du, ich meine, günstigere Stühle ist natürlich, wenn du jetzt da nur mal irgendwie drei Stunden sitzt, weil du ab und zu was spielst oder so, dann würde ich definitiv einen günstigeren Stuhl nehmen.
Also, keine Ahnung, wer diese Faustregel, Faustregel, ach so, du meinst 100 Euro pro Stunde bei einem Stuhl. Ja, finde ich eigentlich gar nicht schlecht, kommt doch hin.
Zehn Stunden sitze ich eh locker am Tag davor, acht Stunden Arbeit, zwei Stunden so locker, locker. Gut, mittlerweile versuche ich ja noch ein bisschen mehr rum zu laufen zwischendurch und einmal nachmittags eineinhalb, zwei Stunden mich immer ordentlich zu bewegen.
Aber dann kommt es preislich umgeflasher hin. Gamingstühle mag ich nicht.
Gamingstühle mag ich nicht. Schreib dich, ja, ich habe einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch, den ich viel zu selten verwende. Was ist an dem besonders? Er ist bequem und er ist dafür gemacht, dass du 24-7 drauf sitzen kannst.
Das ist ja eigentlich ein Stuhl, der gedacht ist für Schichtarbeit in der, keine Ahnung, in der Feuerwehr oder so. Am Notfalltelefon irgendwie sowas, also das schreiben die auch.
Das ist für Schichtarbeiten gedacht, wo wirklich richtig lange am Stück gesessen wird. Und das merkt man, das ist wirklich, also der Stuhl, er sieht vielleicht nicht so aus, aber der ist mega bequem und mega komfortabel.
Und auch dadurch, dass es eben große Armleden hat, hast du auch bei nicht ganz so optimaler Haltung immer noch genug Halt und den tut nicht der Nacken und der Rücken weh.
Hier wäre eine Ahnung, was in Patch-Management abgeht. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass die mit Patch-Management nicht Netzwerkkabel meinen, sondern eher solche Geschichten wie, wir haben eigene Software programmiert, bringen dafür regelmäßig Updates oder aber wir haben eine Farm aus 500 Linux-Servern und die müssen regelmäßig Security-Updates bekommen. Wie macht man das dann?
Wie kann man das möglichst Down-Time-effizient planen und so was? Das vermute ich mal, dass das damit gemeint ist.
Windows-Patches ist ganz einfach. Windows-Patches gibt es nicht, weil man benutzt einfach kein Windows auf dem Server.
Kurze Frage zu SvelteKit. Wann sollte man Endpoints verwenden, anstatt zum Beispiel einen in seine API direkt anzubringen? Endpoints verwendest du dann, wenn du Server-side-rendering machst mit SvelteKit. Du musst ja auf dem Server die Daten schon fetschen, rendern und dann quasi auf den Client rüber schicken. Sonst brauchst du keine Endpoints.
Haben sich deine Uhren umgestellt? Ja, jetzt ist 12.28 Uhr, das ist korrekt.
Ok, hydrate, ganz wichtig Leute. Wir hydraten uns jetzt einfach einmal. Jeder ein bisschen Wasser trinken, Tee oder was auch immer ihr habt.
Ah, yes. Exzellent. Erstmal den High-IQ-Rotwein reinhauen. Nee, es ist einfach nur Wasser.
Hatte schon mehrere Gaming-Stühlen, sind mir eigentlich was abgefallen. Jetzt habe ich einen etwas teuren Gaming-Stühlen, der ist besser, aber die Polster ist... Ja, wie gesagt, ich hatte nur einen DX-Racer, sonst nichts an Gaming-Stühlen und der hat mich so enttäuscht, dass ich gedacht habe, nee, machste nicht mehr.
Ja, machste nicht mehr.
So, schauen wir mal weiter. Also, Day in the Life of Amazon Engineer. Auf geht's.
Hydraten. Ich glaube, das ist gar keine schlechte Idee. Ich mache meistens Toastbrot morgens, weil es schnell geht, aber das ist wahrscheinlich auch zackig.
Das mag ich nicht, diesen komischen Sirup. Die Amis stehen da drauf auf diesen... Was ist denn das? Was ist das für ein Sirup? Die Amis mögen das, ich mag das, das ist nicht mein Fall.
Checking-E-Mails. Ja, Ahornsirup, okay. Checking-E-Mails. Das mache ich auch morgens und danach gucke ich nie wieder rein. Außer irgendjemand sagt, Max, hast du meine Mail gesehen? Die Leute sagen dann nicht, Max, hast du meine Mail gesehen? Die Leute sagen dann, Max, hast du etwa nicht meine Mail gesehen?
Dann muss ich halt sagen, nee, ich gucke kaum in meine Mails noch rein. Wenn was ist, schreibe ihm Teams.
Ist das das Amazon-Office hier? Ach nee, das ist Supermarkt.
Was macht er mit seinem Hund in der Zeit? Das ist eine gute Frage. Entweder kann er den mitnehmen oder da muss er heimbleiben. Vielleicht hat er ja auch eine Frau daheim, keine Ahnung, man weiß es nicht.
Boah, Leute, das wäre mir viel, viel zu lang. Er steht auf um 8, 8.15 Uhr und ist erst 1 Stunde 45. Also ganz ehrlich, ich würde gucken, wenn ich ins Büro müsste und nur 5 Minuten dahin brauche, ich würde um 8.15 Uhr aufstehen und um 8.40 Uhr wäre ich auf der Arbeit, damit ich früher wieder abhauen kann. Ihr wisst, wie das ist. Früher kommen, gleich früher gehen.
Weil wenn du um 10 Uhr erst anfängst zu arbeiten und 8 Stunden arbeitest, da kommst du erst um 18 Uhr da raus. Das ist viel, viel zu spät. 15.30 Uhr. Bei mir ist es immer so, wenn ich nach Frankfurt gehe, 15.30 Uhr fällt der Hammer. Und der fällt dann auch. Egal, ob da einer Meeting einlädt oder nicht.
Wollen die alle immer mit ihrem MacBook? Ja gut, Keyboard mitbringen würde ich auch machen, weil davon abgesehen, ich habe mein Keyboard halt da liegen. Übrigens schicke Monitore. So ein Curved Monitor ist tatsächlich nice.
Alter, die Musik mach ich mit dem Coding Time. Was ist das für eine Tastatur?
Die Maus? Moment, wo ist das? Ist das die Maus? Nee. Nee, das ist so ganz normale Logitech oder so. Alter, damit könnte ich mit der Tastatur nicht klarkommen.
Theoretisch ist das ergonomisch bestimmt voll nice, weil du deine Hände ergonomischer liegen hast als so nach innen. Aber glaube ich, damit würde ich nicht klarkommen.
Nebenbei hat er irgendwie die Lofi Stream am Laufen im Hochkant-Format. Daily Stand-Up, wenigstens steht er nicht dabei, das finde ich schon mal gut.
Okay, es wird doch gestand upped.
Wisst ihr was ich immer äußerst spannend finde? Das habe ich jetzt auch schon in anderen Technik, so Daily Arbeit, Technik-Unternehmen gesehen. Die haben immer so super krasse Chill-Räume überall, aber nie sitzt da einer.
Ich glaube, das ist eher so nach dem Motto, guck mal hier, wie cool das ist, du kannst hier abchillen, aber eigentlich sollst du gefälligst arbeiten. Das heißt, wer da sitzt und abchillt ist eigentlich nicht am Arbeiten.
Das ist eher so nach dem Motto, man könnte, aber man kann nicht. Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, bevor ich da rumgammel, gammele ich lieber draußen oder daheim rum.
Ja, das ist wie Tischkicker oder sowas. So abgesehen, ich bin kein großer Tischkicker-Fan oder Konsolen, die irgendwie rumstehen oder sowas.
Was jetzt ganz fertig ist? Was? Hä? Was exakt, was macht der da? Das blick ich jetzt nicht durch. Okay, hier mietet er, hier mietet er, das habe ich verstanden.
Okay, 12.15 Uhr ist er fertig mieten. Was zum Teufel ist das denn? Hä? Das ist irgendwie so.
Keine Ahnung, da kannst du hier genauso gut Heilsteine auf die Füße legen oder so. Hipstergedöns, ja, Hipstergedöns trifft es ganz gut.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Das habe ich nicht gecheckt, was das jetzt sein soll.
Es sieht äußerst gesund aus. Die Sache ist nur die. Jetzt mal ehrlich, jetzt mal ernsthaft, jetzt mal ernsthaft. Also es sieht gut aus, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich davon satt werden würde.
Ich meine, guck mal, das sind drei Tacos oder sowas. Also wenn die mir drei Teller geben würden, okay, vielleicht.
Da ist keiner da, ne?
Alle Homeoffice. Oh doch, da hinten sitzen welche, guck mal, da hinten hinter ihm sitzen welche.
Bananas. Ich muss sagen, es ist erstaunlich wenig arbeiten dabei.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt schon 13 Uhr. Er hat um 10 Uhr angefangen und davon hat er fast eine halbe Stunde programmiert oder so.
Eine Stunde? Ich meine, ich finde das durchaus, wie soll ich sagen, es ist ja realistisch.
Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, wie das manchen Chefs vorschwebt, dass du wirklich 5-6 Stunden am Tag konzentriert Technikkram machst.
Das ist ja nicht so. Du kannst dich keine 5-6 Stunden so konzentrieren, dass du sinnvoll, produktive, komplizierte Sachen machst.
Das funktioniert ja nicht. Aber ich kann Sachen am besten Vormittags erledigen.
Also ich würde wahrscheinlich den kompletten Vormittag 3 Stunden dann programmieren und nach Möglichkeit Nachmittags mieten.
Ah, die sind alle so glücklich, dass sie bei Amazon sind. Alles klar.
Was machen die den ganzen Tag?
Ich könnte so überhaupt nicht arbeiten. Ich könnte so nicht arbeiten. Das funktioniert nicht.
Damit ich ordentlich was geschafft kriege, ich muss auf einem ordentlichen Stuhl sitzen, ich brauche eine ordentliche Tastatur, ich brauche eine ordentliche Maus,
ich brauche zwei Monitore vor mir und ich brauche vor allem einfach mal 2, 3, 4 Stunden Ruhe, wo mir drumherum nichts auf den Sack geht.
3 Stunden am Stück. Wunderbar. Aber gut, jeder wie er mag.
Wahrscheinlich beantwortet er jetzt die E-Mails von morgens.
Es ist 15.30 Uhr. Gut, ich meine kein Wunder, dass du keinen Feierabend machen kannst, wenn du nur eine Stunde gearbeitet hast seit 10.
Da muss man schon mal wirklich eine Pause machen bei der eine Stunde Arbeit.
Okay, das kann natürlich krasser. Da hat er recht. Das sollte ich auch eher machen, anstatt hier sinnlos vorm Rechner zu sitzen gerade.
Duschen in der Firma. Krasser Scheiß. Aber warum? Warum nicht einfach ordentlich vormittags arbeiten und dann mittags heimgehen?
Mal eine Banane futtern. 16.40 Uhr wird mal wieder ein bisschen was geschafft.
18.45 Uhr. Da habe ich schon ein YouTube-Video aufgenommen und den Twitch-Stream an in der Zwischenzeit.
Okay, das wird im YouTube-Video aufgenommen in letzter Zeit nicht so, aber ihr wisst woran es liegt.
Hey, es soll jeder von den Zeiten her einteilen, wie er will. Ich habe da kein Problem mit. Also ich will euch jetzt nicht sagen, dass man so machen soll oder nicht. Aber für mich wäre das viel zu spät. 15.30 Uhr ist wirklich das allerspäteste. Da fällt der Hammer. 15.30 Uhr ist vorbei. 15.30 Uhr ist Schluss, wenn ich nach Frankfurt muss.
Daheim meistens so bis 16 Uhr. Und dann 1,5 bis 2 Stunden raus und dann Rest. Moment, ist das jetzt noch bei Amazon? Nee, das ist irgendwie drum herum.
Der Hund ist aber auch ganz schön lange allein daheim, oder? YouTube checken. Jawoll. Ohne Gassi.
Das ist so eine Mischung. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das beschreiben soll. Diese Jobs, diese Jobvideos, das wirkt immer wie eine Mischung aus hipster Arbeit und coolem Lifestyle zeigen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das anders beschreiben soll. Ich weiß nicht, wie realistisch das ist.
Ja, um 20.30 Uhr kann man sich immer langsam was bequemes anziehen.
Aha. Also es ist 21.30 Uhr. Ihr wisst, was 21.30 Uhr bei mir ist, oder? Chat. Welches Chat-Kommando passt bei mir am besten für 21.30 Uhr? Nicht Boomer? Ja, genau. Ausrufezeichen spät.
Um 20.30 Uhr bin ich müde. Alter, es ist 23 Uhr. Es ist 23.15 Uhr.
Ich war es ja nett.
Mal kurz Comments gucken.
Ich kann dazu nichts sagen. Ich bin nur ein 37-jähriger Boomer, der bei einer rückständigen deutschen Bank arbeitet.
Das kann man wahrscheinlich nicht mit Amazon vergleichen, aber mir erscheint immer noch so die Ratio Work zu Rest irgendwie unbalanced bei diesen Videos.
Die machen immer irgendwie gefühlt vier Stunden Pause und zigtausend Sachen da immer noch am Tag.
Ich wäre meine siebeneinhalb Stunden da, würde mich davon nach Möglichkeit gerne drei Stunden konzentrieren, dass ich sinnvoll was machen kann.
Restlichen Tag würde ich dann mit Daily Meetings und sonstigen Gedulds verbringen, aber so auf jeden Fall, dass ich 15.30 Uhr heimgehen kann.
Hat er nur vier Tage? Nee, er hat wahrscheinlich fünf Tage, kann ich mir vorstellen. Ja, genau.
Aber wie gesagt, jeder wie er will.
Was wollten ihr, dass ich mir noch angucke? Ich habe langsam aber sicher auch Hunger. Nee.
Irgendetwas meint ihr doch, müssen wir unbedingt gucken. Irgendetwas wollte der Chat doch haben. Informatik studieren, so schwer ist das wirklich.
Gut, kann ich halt nicht so viel sagen. Ich habe nicht keine Informatik studiert, aber mal schauen. Was ist das erste, was wir hier sehen?
HTML, Block Body Attribute und dann irgendwelche komischen JavaScript Escape Syntax Dinger.
Würdest du es empfehlen, nach der Ausbildung in Teilzeit zu gehen? Naja, das kommt auf dich an.
Also ich würde es prinzipiell immer empfehlen, in Teilzeit zu gehen, weil du einfach viel mehr von deinem Leben hast.
Und du generell, wenn du in der IT arbeitest, meistens nicht gerade am Hungertuch nagsst, dass du wirklich jeden letzten Euro brauchst und man in der Regel einen Tag weniger Gehalt ganz gut verkraftet.
Ja, und du hast einfach mehr Zeit für dein normales Leben. Also ich würde es immer empfehlen, Teilzeit zu arbeiten. Aber letztendlich musst du das wissen.
Wenn du irgendeine Familie hast, du hast dir gerade ein Haus gekauft und musst das abbezahlen oder was auch immer, dann ist es vielleicht keine so gute Idee, in Teilzeit zu gehen.
Das hängt aber von dir ab. Rein so von, wie soll man sagen, so balance-technisch finde ich, ist Teilzeit arbeiten das Beste, was man machen kann.
Wenn man mehr Zeit für sich haben will bzw. für sein Leben oder seine Familie oder halt, dass man mehr Zeit hat, das zu machen, was man machen will.
Wenn man jetzt natürlich der harte Karriere-Krinder ist, der sagt, mein größtes Ziel ist, in der Firma, wo ich arbeite, vorwärts zu kommen und da vielleicht mal irgendwann, was weiß ich, Chef-Entwickler, Blah, was auch immer, XY zu werden, dann ist vielleicht Teilzeit arbeiten nicht das Beste.
Es kommt immer drauf an, was du für Ziele hast und was du machen willst.
Da kann man sich jetzt rüber streiten. Tja, auf der anderen Seite könnte man sagen, hey, die frühen Jahre sind auch die, wo du noch besonders fit und besonders auf Zack bist, wo du vielleicht auch gerade die Zeit außerhalb des Jobs gerade für Sachen verwenden könntest, wo du sonst keine Zeit machst oder was du später nicht mehr machen kannst.
Also das ist ganz individuell. Also ich kann es prinzipiell nur empfehlen, wenn man den einen Tag, die Woche oder was weiß ich, je nachdem, wie viel man verkraften kann, ein weniger Geld zu bekommen, kann ich das immer nur empfehlen, Teilzeit zu arbeiten, weil du einfach viel mehr Zeit hast für das, was du gerne machen willst.
Und ja, es gibt manche, die arbeiten auch gerne, aber trotzdem ist es nicht das Leben.
Sieben, vier Tage acht Stunden, ganz klar. Vier Tage acht Stunden ist deutlich besser als sieben, finde ich, als sieben Stunden fünf Stunden, sieben Stunden, sieben oder acht Stunden merkst du doch gar keinen großen Unterschied.
Zumal dann dein Chef von dir auch will, dass du so viel schaffst, wie jemand, der vier, der, der acht Stunden, ne, ne, vier Tage oder ein Tag nicht da sein ist das Beste.
Ja, ja, eindeutig.
Ob man die Ausbildung in Teilzeit machen sollte, keine Ahnung, kommt drauf an, wie viel du da wirklich lernst.
Ausbildung finde ich ist eine der Sachen, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das durchaus sinnvoll ist, das zu machen.
Also das nicht in Teilzeit zu machen, aber danach, es kommt immer, es kommt wirklich individuell auf die Leute an.
Das macht aber nicht jeder Mann so nebenbei.
Es ist jetzt ja auch nicht so easy, dass du mal nebenbei arbeiten gehst und dann mal kurz abends noch Informatik studierst.
Also das erfordert harte Disziplin, high IQ und Durchhaltevermögen. So, so nebenbei ist das jetzt auch nicht gemacht.
Ich kenne einen, der MasterCrabber, der, der Real Life Freund vom Friseur und von Fabian und mir, der hat das, der Karsten,
mit dem ich schon in seiner Ewigkeit mal ein Video aufnehmen will, aber der sich immer davor gedrückt hat, der hat das gemacht.
Der hat abends studiert, der hat sein Abi nachgemacht und danach abends studiert, während er normal gearbeitet hat.
Das ist mega krass. Und der Karsten, das darf man nicht vergessen, der Karsten ist super, wie soll ich sagen, fokussiert bei sowas, wenn er sowas macht.
Also der hat wirklich, wie nennt man das, Disziplin und Durchhaltevermögen und, und der Karsten ist high IQ.
Der hat irgendwie einen EQ von 140 oder so. Also für den ist das kein Ding.
Quatsch nicht, nicht Allotrix. Allotrix hätte in der Zeit 20 Weiber im Willpool klar gemacht.
Aber der andere Karsten hat nebenbei studiert und gearbeitet. Ich meine auch den Karsten mit K.
Ja, der hat Durchhaltevermögen, ist motiviert und ist wirklich schlau. Der hat das geschafft und für den war es auch mega anstrengend.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das so für die meisten eine gute Variante ist. So, aber dann gucken wir uns jetzt mal an. Informatikstudien schwer oder nicht?
Jetzt das Prüfungsergebnis kam, der Schock nicht bestanden. Ich hatte sehr viel Angst, dass...
Zebaro, Zebaro, falls du da bist, wie läuft eigentlich dein Informatikstudium? Wo ist der CuteMod?
Der CuteMod war schon ewig nicht mehr da. Kennt den CuteMod überhaupt noch irgendeiner? Wo ist er?
Dass ich mein Traumstudium in Informatik nicht weiter studieren kann. Das war anspruchsvoller als am Anfang erwartet.
Ich glaube, das geht vielen so. Gerade die Mathe-Geschichte ist das, was viele Leute abfackt oder viele im Hirn nicht hinbekommen.
Ich bin Richard, ich bin 22 Jahre alt und ich studiere Bachelorangewandte Informatik, mittlerweile im neunten Semester an der Technischen Universität Chemnitz.
Die Informatik interessiert mich schon seitdem ich mehr oder weniger in der fünften Klasse bin. Mein Bruder hatte damals angefangen Informatik zu studieren, hat das leider nicht geschafft.
Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, ich mache es besser, habe mich ein bisschen in den Computer reingearbeitet, dann in die Programmierung.
Immer mehr gemerkt, wie viel Spaß mir das macht, habe festgestellt, dass ich...
Unity gedönnt oder? Nee.
Lampe. Get Lampe Nummer. Seriously.
Wie?
Get Lampe Nummer.
Das ist nicht Unity, oder? Was ist denn das?
Ist das Unreal? Könnte das C++ sein? Nee, oder?
JavaScript? Ist das JavaScript? Nee, ich habe keine Ahnung was das ist. Normalerweise erkennt man das ja immer relativ schnell.
Es sieht nicht aus wie C Sharp, nee.
Es ist Express? JavaScript Express oder so?
Keine Ahnung. Die Programmierung. Immer mehr gemerkt, wie viel Spaß mir das macht, habe festgestellt, dass ich einfach alles machen kann, was ich möchte.
Naja, so einfach ist es jetzt ja auch wieder nicht. Also ich möchte auch viel und kann davor garantiert nicht alles programmieren.
Wir sind gerade beim Kalibrieren des Sightrackers.
Wenn du da reinkommst, dann müssen wir gucken, wie das von deiner Hose passt, setzt sich ruhig bequem hin.
Ich erhoffe mir vom Experiment, dass ich damit den Fatsam-Kleinteil, die informatische Forschung vorantreiben kann und gleichzeitig ein bisschen Einblick in meinen Denken bekommen kann,
während ich in der Informatik arbeite, während ich programmiere oder mir Code angucke.
Ich würde dich bitten, dass du dir die Sätze anguckst und dann entscheidest, ob die richtig sind oder falsch. Dafür nehmen wir dich auf mit einem Diktiergerät.
Ich werde im Endeffekt verschiedene informatische Ausdrücke bekommen, also mehr oder weniger Sätze nur in Programmier-Slang.
Und ich werde anhand dieser Sachen bewerten, ob die Aussage falsch oder wahr ist.
Ich werde ein EEG aufsetzen und am Hand von Eye-Tracking-Verfahren wird herausgefunden, wie ich auf die Code-Schnipsel reagiere.
Der Acker, man.
Da müsste ich zuerst an den ehemaligen Telekom-Chef denken.
Moment, was?
Was man denkt, wenn man diesen Code-Schnipsel sieht?
Ich denke, es sieht aus wie Java und ich will es mir eigentlich nicht länger angucken.
Wir sehen hier diese ganzen Hirnströme.
Ja, der hat Java gesehen und hat gleich gedacht, Rage Quit.
Könnte auch eine Überraschung für mich rauskommen. Mittlerweile tendiere ich eher dazu, mich ein bisschen zu überschätzen durch meine Arbeit.
Und dass ich dort immer gutes Feedback kriege.
Also quasi erfindet sich zu geil, oder wie?
Deswegen kann es sein, dass ich mich überschätze unter anderem.
Und ich kann mich auch ein bisschen überschätzen, wenn ich etwas überschätze, wenn ich etwas überschätze, wenn ich etwas überschätze.
Also quasi erfindet sich zu geil, oder wie? Deswegen kann es sein, dass ich mich überschätze, unterschätze.
Doppelpack Informatik.
Das ist eins der beschissensten.
Man spielt einen Tic Tac mehr oder weniger, eine Kapsel.
Das sieht aus wie ein Minecraft Jump Parkour. Und ansonsten, was was man in einer, was weiß ich, was man im Unity Editor in 20 Minuten zusammenzieht oder so?
Und springt mit, der über die Plattform und versucht durch die insgesamt 50 Level durchzukommen.
Okay, es gibt 50 Level, dann ist natürlich ein bisschen mehr.
Um ein Spiel zu entwickeln. Am Anfang wollte ich auch Spielentwickler werden, das hat sich mittlerweile geändert. Jetzt will ich nochmal Softwareentwickler werden.
Dann habe ich mich ein bisschen informiert, wo man alles Informatik studieren kann.
Und habe herausgefunden, dass im Endeffekt der Schmittler Universität Chemnitz einen guten Ruf in der Informatik hat.
Chemnitz.
Und das hat mich dann im Endeffekt dazu bewegt, hier zu studieren.
Es gibt bei uns einerseits die Basismodule, die muss jeder belegen. Dazu gehören beispielsweise die Mathe-Module oder auch Algorithmen und Programme.
Ja, das ist natürlich was anderes. Das ist das, was viele Leute Probleme machen.
Es gibt dann noch fortführend die Vertiefungs-Module. Wenn mich jetzt etwas Besonderes interessiert, dann kann ich mich da auf diesen Bereich spezialisieren.
Erst mal den binary tree inwarten, Leute.
Kann ich mich zum Beispiel auf die Medieninformatik spezialisieren.
Für mich war die schwerste Prüfung die Mathe-Prüfung.
Wenn man eine Prüfung schreibt, dann hat man insgesamt dafür drei Versuche.
Wenn man jetzt Mathe 1 beispielsweise dreimal nicht...
Kann man da nicht übelst cheaten, wenn man Klausuren im Homeoffice schreibt?
... steht, dann darf man nirgendwo in Deutschland mehr Informatik studieren.
Beim ersten Mal habe ich die Mathe-Prüfung etwas unterschätzt.
Ich habe nicht genug Zeit ins Lernen rein investiert.
Ich habe die Aufgaben gemacht, die wir als Prüfungsvorleistung machen mussten und dachte, damit bin ich gut genug vorbereitet.
Und dann habe ich die Prüfung geschrieben.
Ich habe schon gemerkt, das lief nicht ganz so gut, vielleicht reicht es ja gerade so.
Und dann, als das Prüfungsergebnis kam, der Schock nicht bestanden.
Da gibt es einen Save Exam Browser.
Das einfachste, was mir einfallen würde, ist, warum kannst du nicht einfach...
Also ich weiß nicht, ob man sich damit filmen muss oder so mit Webcam.
Ansonsten kann man doch einfach jemanden neben sich setzen, der Ahnung hat davon.
Webcam muss.
Aha, aha.
Okay, dann ist das ähnlich wie über Microsoft-Zertifikaten.
Da darf noch nicht mal jemand ins Zimmer kommen zwischendurch.
Wiederholungsprüfung davon, sehr viel gelernt.
Ich habe sehr viel Zeit rein investiert, auch noch mal die Aufgaben gemacht.
Leider hat das Ganze auch nicht geholfen und ich habe es dann im Endeffekt wieder nicht bestanden.
Als ich das zweite Mal durchgefallen bin, war ich sehr aufgeregt und hatte sehr viel Angst,
dass ich mein Traumstudium in Informatik nicht weiter studieren kann.
Wenn man gerade vor dem Drittversuch steht und Angst hat, dass man vielleicht nicht weiter studieren kann,
dann ist das ein sehr beklemmendes Gefühl.
So war es auf jeden Fall damals für mich.
Ich hatte wirklich eine unglaubliche Angst, dass ich mein Studium nicht schaffe.
Kannst du mir vorstellen.
Das kann ich mir echt vorstellen, dass das mega belastend ist.
Das dritte Semester meines Studiums, also ganz am Anfang.
Ich wusste nicht, was ich danach hätte machen sollen, weil kein Studium hätte mir so viel Spaß gemacht wie die Informatik.
Direkt nachdem ich die Klausur geschrieben habe, habe ich jeden Tag immer wieder online reingeguckt,
ob jetzt das Ergebnis da ist und habe dann endlich gesehen, dass ich bestanden habe und war superglücklich.
Er hat bestanden mit was?
Wo steht die Note? Ist das die Note? 4?
Okay, 5 ist durchgefallen, 4 ist gerade noch so bestanden.
Close, close call, Alter.
Knapp, knapp.
Close.
Und habe dann endlich gesehen, dass ich bestanden habe und war superglücklich.
Und habe erstmal ein paar Freunden gefeiert.
Was waren für euch als Informatiker oder schon Informatik-Studierende die größten Herausforderungen?
Keine Ahnung, ich habe keine Informatik studiert.
Schreibt das in die Kommentare.
Und falls ihr noch nicht Informatik studiert, dann könnt ihr euch hier darüber informieren.
Es ist ein kleines bisschen aufgeregt.
Ich habe das Experiment zwar schon mal gemacht, aber noch nicht in diesem Umfang, in dem ich es jetzt mache.
Mich würde echt interessieren, wie es beim Sebaro läuft.
Was immer sehr spannend ist.
Okay, wenn du bereit bist, dann würden wir jetzt starten.
Perfekt.
Oh, das ist Intelligenztest, sowas in der Richtung.
So nach dem Motto, erkennen Sie die richtige Reihenfolge und sowas.
Das Schwierigste an der Aufgabe für mich wird sein, mich genug darauf zu konzentrieren,
dass ich immer die richtige Lösung gebe, was ich natürlich wahrscheinlich nicht hinkriegen werde,
was aber natürlich auch der eigene Anspruch ist.
Zwischen der Grammatik-Desetzer und dem bisher gezeigten Automaten.
Haftog-Riff.
Pfeiferzeug.
Richtig.
Dann geben wir einen Komma.
Prüf.
Will einer Brainfuck-Konkurrenz machen?
Oder wie?
Falsch, das wäre Präf.
Alles klar, das war's schon.
Super, danke, dass du mitgemacht hast.
Sehr gerne.
Wie hast du dich gefühlt?
Das war sehr gerne.
Gib mir jetzt bitte schon die Unterschrift auf dem Dokument, dass ich weitermachen kann.
Am Ende war ich ein bisschen raus bei den Aufgaben.
Ein bisschen Nervosität war von Anfang an dabei, aber hat sich mit der Zeit immer mehr gelegt.
An der Universität ist es so, wie es hier auch ist, dass sehr viel theoretisch gelehrt wird.
Es wird versucht, in einer gewissen Art und Weise auch Praxis näherzubringen,
indem man zum Beispiel kleine Programmieraufgaben hat.
Wenn man die aber sich anschaut, dann sind sie zum Teil ein bisschen fern ab dem,
was man normalerweise programmieren würde.
So richtig Praxiserfahrung muss man eigentlich dann sammeln mit den Sachen,
die einem Spaß machen, indem man das selber macht.
Ah, guck mal da.
Der kommt mir doch bekannt vor.
Das ist aber noch nicht mein S5, das ist glaube ich noch ein S3 oder sowas.
Das ist noch ein älterer.
Der Roborock.
Das selber macht.
Gemeinsam erstellen meine Freundin und ich ein Smart Home System.
By the way, auf dem Staubsauger-Roboter läuft Ubuntu 12.04 drauf.
Kein Witz, ich hab selbst einen, deswegen weiß ich das.
Ubuntu 12.04 und ich glaube mit einem Software-Update haben sie abgecraded auf Ubuntu 14.04.
Also ja, man kann sich theoretisch per SSH auf ein voll funktionsfähiges ARM Linux verbinden mit seinem Staubsauger.
Es gibt zwar schon viele Smart Home System, meistens sind die aber von unterschiedlichen Herstellern.
Ja, deswegen nennt man einfach Home Assistant.
Außerdem sind die nicht so sicher wie ein lokales, was nur in unserem Netzwerk läuft.
Deswegen nennt man einfach Home Assistant.
Und wir machen das als Team, das heißt wir teilen uns nicht ein, wer was macht, heute wollten wir ausprobieren.
Da muss man, ich mein zum Lernen, ich sag da ja überhaupt nichts dagegen.
Lernen ist das sicher nicht eine super Geschichte.
Dann lernst du auf allen Ebenen was, von ein bisschen minimalistischer Hardware bis Webinterface bis Backend-Technologie.
Aber natürlich kommt da nichts Sinnvolles bei rum.
Es gibt so Sachen wie IOU-Broker, es gibt Sachen wie Home Assistant, die sind fertig und sind für genau solche Einsatzzwecke gedacht.
Und sowas machst du auch mal nicht nebenbei nur mit zwei Leuten.
Dass wir unseren kleinen Staubsauger, Robby heißt der, dass der losläuft, wenn wir auf den Button drücken, das heißt wir müssen jetzt den Button da einfügen.
Und wir müssen dann noch dafür sorgen, dass es eine Funktion gibt, die dann dafür sorgen, dass er losläuft.
Ist das PHP, Leute? Kann das sein, dass es PHP ist?
Da hab ich vorhin gar nicht dran gedacht. Ach nee.
Was ist das?
Das ist Pisces. Sekunde.
Ja, tatsächlich.
Das könnte wirklich was wie Django oder so sein, ne?
Doch, doch, das könnte durchaus, das könnte schon Pisces sein.
Also von der Sündachs her ist das möglich.
Jetzt erkenne ich auch, was das ist. Das liegt daran, habe ich so gut wie nie was mitgemacht.
Wir versuchen, ihn jetzt zu starten, das heißt wir öffnen die Seite, dann den mal neu und drücken auf Robby an.
Und wie wir merken, merken wir nichts. Im Endeffekt läuft der Roboter nicht los.
Anzeige ist raus.
Das muss ich erst mal herausfinden, dafür müssen wir das machen.
Und gucken, was jetzt genau der Fehler ist.
Also der Fehler, warum es nicht losläuft, ist doch wahrscheinlich nicht im JavaScript Frontend zu suchen, oder?
Ja.
Da läuft bestimmt, ich weiß nicht, ob der Hüpfer da ist, da läuft bestimmt Falle Tudo drauf.
Wird passen.
Weil ansonsten müsstest du das über die Show-Me-Api machen.
Und das ist eklig.
Funktioniert jetzt endlich.
Mein Rat für die Leute, die jetzt anfangen wollen, Informatik zu studieren, oder bald anfangen wollen, Informatik zu studieren, ist, sucht euch irgendeine Programmiersprache,
programmiert etwas, setzt euch schwerere Aufgaben, programmiert die dann auch.
Und dann klappt auch das Studium, sucht euch auch während des Studiums ein paar Aufgaben, die euch spaßen.
Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, das meiste, was den Leuten Probleme macht, ist wie bei ihm, die Mathe-Teile, die Mathe-Parts.
Das andere kriegt man, glaube ich, alles hin, aber ich glaube, für Mathe musst du wirklich richtig intensiv lernen.
Vor allem, weil das halt auch was ist, wo die meisten Leute jetzt nicht so in Kontakt gekommen sind vorher.
Weil das, was du da in der Schule gemacht hast, kannst du wahrscheinlich absolut null mit dem vergleichen, was du da dir angucken musst.
Welche Sprache würdest du empfehlen?
Witzigerweise, wir haben dazu mal ein Video gemacht, wobei er heißt jetzt ja anders. Wir haben ein Video zusammen gemacht zu genau diesem Thema.
Das ist schon ein bisschen her. Hier. Max. Ist schon so lange her.
Welche Programmiersprache für den Einstieg?
Wir haben ein Video zugemacht, gibt es bei ihm und bei mir auf dem Channel. Also im Prinzip würde ich sagen, wenn du noch gar keine genauen Vorstellungen hast, mit was du anfangen willst, wo man eigentlich nichts falsch machen kannst, ist ein bisschen JavaScript.
HTML, CSS, JavaScript aus mehreren Gründen. Das erste ist, du brauchst nichts Großartiges. Du brauchst im Endeffekt einen Texteditor und einen Browser. Du kannst loslegen.
Und das zweite ist, JavaScript, HTML, CSS braucht man eh immer. Es ist egal, ob du später im Backendbereich, sonst wo landest, ein bisschen Frontend Zeug muss eigentlich heutzutage jeder können.
Auch jeder Admin und was auch immer. Jemand, der vielleicht sonst gar nichts großartig mit Programmieren zu tun hat. Aber ein bisschen Frontendentwicklung musst du heute eigentlich fast überall, du willst ein bisschen können.
Und nachdem du quasi nichts zum Einstieg brauchst, finde ich, ist JavaScript, CSS, HTML das Beste zum Anfang. Wenn du natürlich genaue Vorstellungen schon hast, was du machen willst.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, ja, ich möchte unbedingt irgendwas Machine Learning mäßiges machen oder ich will irgendwelche Cloud Geschichten machen oder ich will Linux Server Anwendung machen, gibt es vielleicht bessere Sachen.
Aber grundsätzlich glaube ich, kann man nicht viel falsch machen mit JavaScript, HTML, CSS. Zumal man braucht es eh immer und es gibt halt so viele Tutorials und Hilfeseiten und Videoserien und alles.
Game Entwicklung, ja gut, da bleibt ja im Prinzip nur Unity und C-Sharp. Außer Unreal vielleicht noch. Aber einsteigertechnisch denke ich ist eindeutig Unity dank C-Sharp besser als irgendwelche C++ Unreal Geschichten.
Wenn es um Game Entwicklung geht, bleibt ja im Prinzip nur C-Sharp Unity. Dafür findest du ja auch Millionen an Tutorials und Sachen.
C++, alter, hör mal bloß auf. Das stimmt auch, wenn du eine Sprache gut kannst, kannst du zumindest Sprachen, die ähnliche Anlagen haben, relativ schnell programmieren.
Rust ist die einzige Ausnahme, da gibt mir der Patrick wahrscheinlich auch recht. Rust ist, selbst wenn du gut C, C++, C-Sharp, Python, Ruby, was auch immer kannst, ist Rust erstmal nur für 140 IQ-Plus-Leute schnell zu lernen. Alle anderen müssen sich da ein bisschen durchquälen.
Aber dafür ist Rust, aber dafür ist Rust, wie soll ich sagen, ich hab ja ganz, als Rust neu war, mich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, dafür ist Rust so ein Ding, das kann man schwer beschreiben.
Rust fuck dich ab, dafür kannst du dir aber zumindest sicher sein, dass es memorytechnisch keine Probleme in deinem Programm gibt und du denkst nach einer Weile Rust programmieren, automatisch an solche Sachen, wie geht diese Variable aus dem Scope, ohne dass ich sie aufgeräumt habe oder läuft dieser Thread länger als er laufen sollte und solche Geschichten.
Da denkst du normalerweise gar nicht dran, in dieser Klarheit, aber Rust trainiert einen da ein bisschen drauf durch diesen ganzen Borrow Checker und man könnte sagen, ich glaube, wenn man sich intensiv mit Rust beschäftigt, man wird zum besseren Programmierer durch. Ob ich Rust jetzt als Main-Sprache nehmen würde, eher nicht, aber Rust ist eine coole Sache.
Ruby, ja, Ruby hab ich auch immer gerne verwendet, Ruby ist immer noch eines meiner Lieblings-, also Mit-Lieblings-Programmiersprachen, aber mittlerweile ist Ruby leider ein bisschen dank dem Zugrundegehen von Rails quasi ein bisschen weniger gefragt worden.
Da hab ich letztens eine Umfrage gesehen, die ich absolut nicht verstanden habe, ich glaube, bei Heise oder so.
Der Weg zum gefragten Programmierer, da hab ich irgendeine Umfrage gesehen, ne, das war's anderes, die ich nicht verstanden hab, wo ich mir gedacht hab, was zum Teufel ist da los?
Hier, beliebteste Programmiersprachen, höchsten Gehälter, das, was da rauskommt, deckt sich so überhaupt nicht mit meinen Erfahrungen, guckt euch das mal an.
Also erstens muss man sagen, Programmiersprachen, und dann listen sie hier gefühlt jedes JavaScript-Framework auf. Go ist die meistgefragte Sprache, Go ist sicherlich nicht irrelevant, aber die meistgefragte Sprache, da hab ich irgendwie meine Zweifel dran.
Ruby on Rails auf Platz 2, the fuck, Ruby on Rails, Alter, im Jahr 2022, wollen die mich verarschen, Scala, dritter Platz, vor Java, vor sich, was zum Teufel, was, was ist das?
Na, da kommt Ruby gleich dahinter, Ruby ohne Rails benutzt keine Sau mehr, React Native ist das erste, was ich mir hier gefallen lasse,
Kotlin TypeScript lasse ich mir auch noch, Kafka, das ist noch nicht mal eine Programmiersprache, das ist eine Message-Queue, das hat doch überhaupt nichts drin zu suchen.
Hier steht Programmiersprachen, achso, IT-Skills, na super, das stimmt die Überschrift noch nicht mal, Node.js, vor allem, warum ist kein JavaScript als Sprache da, sondern irgendwelche komischen Objective-C,
hier ist Java zum ersten Mal am Start mit Spring Boot, also das ist eine ganz, ganz furchtbar wirre Umfrage, die ich nicht nachvollziehen kann.
Entwicklerbefortzung, ja, aber Entwicklerbefortung hat ja mit dem hier nichts zu tun, versteh ich nicht, also das, das, das hab ich nicht gecheckt.
Das hab ich nicht kapiert, das war mir zu advanced, achso, das ist ja noch nicht fertig, wir sollten das vielleicht mal fertig gucken.
Die sollten mal lieber rausfinden, wie gut er Mathe lernt.
Ich mach jetzt keinen Witz über den Microsoft Support, sonst sind Leute triggert.
Warum reden die in Chemnitz eigentlich Englisch?
Interessanteste für mich war vor allem in der Impelsprechung noch die Zusammenhänge zu sehen zwischen dem normalen Sprachenlernen,
was man in der Schule auch macht und dem Programmiersprachenlernen, gleichzeitig hat das Experiment mir gezeigt, dass ich inzwischen...
Das ist nicht in Amerika, das ist in Chemnitz, austauschst du ja, das kann tatsächlich sein.
Wisst ihr was mich daran erinnert? Das ist, wer war das, der das erzählt hat, der Oettinger?
Der Oettinger, Englisch wird die Arbeitssprache.
Auf die Syntax achten muss, weil sonst natürlich Fehler entstehen und das möchte ein Programmierer nicht in seinem Code haben, Syntaxfehler.
Aber gleichzeitig waren meine Denkmuster und meine Sehmuster sehr gut und haben im Endeffekt genau das Richtige gemacht.
Also er hat das Richtige gedacht, exzellent.
Das Spannendste daran ist eigentlich, dass ich besser die Denkmuster verstehen kann und auch sehen kann, was sind gute Denkmuster,
wie sollte man über kurz scannen, um den schnell zu verstehen und das brauche ich natürlich auch für meine Bachelorarbeit.
Aha, wie alt ist der, weiß ich nicht, ob wir das gesagt haben, 22? Nee, 22 war der Fortnite-Streamer.
Keine Ahnung, haben wir das gesagt, wie alt der ist? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich habe eine Idee und ich setze sie um und dann funktioniert das, jedenfalls solange es meinen Programmier-Talent zulässt
und das war im Endeffekt der Grund, dass ich mich für das Informatik-Studium wünsche.
Du bist toll.
Gute Mathe-Kenntnisse ist, glaube ich, gar nicht so entscheidend.
Entscheidend ist, dass man sich darauf einlässt und halt den Scheiß lernt, weil das, was du in der Schule an Mathe gelernt hast,
Leute, sagt mir, wenn ich falsch liege, aber ich glaube nicht, dass die Mathe-Kenntnisse, die du aus der Schule mitbringst,
dir bei dieser Mathe, bei diesem Ansatz dort wirklich viel bringen.
Ich denke mal, du musst dich darauf einlassen und du musst wahrscheinlich wirklich viel lernen dafür.
Aus der Schule hat mir gar nichts geholfen, das dachte ich mir, deswegen ist gute Mathe-Kenntnisse eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Tja, ne, ja gut.
Home-Automation-Idee ist nah, das gucken wir jetzt nicht mehr.
Leute, ich bin jetzt dreieinhalb Stunden und ich habe mega Hunger, ich gehe jetzt was essen
und ich überlege noch, ob ich irgendjemand hosten kann.
Die großen brauchen das alle nicht.
Keiner da.
Es ist schon so spät.
Eigentlich habe ich mir überlegt, ob ich heute nicht doch wirklich noch mal ein YouTube-Video zu der Battlefield-Geschichte aufnehme,
wo ich vorher kurz angesprochen habe.
Nein, nein, nein, M-Core hat seine Kanal nicht verkauft.
Der Account wurde gehackerment.
M-Core, der hat sein Channel verloren.
Ich weiß das, weil er mich angeschrieben hat.
Ja.
M-Core ist jetzt kein Krypto-Bro geworden über Nacht.
Die versuchen gerade den Channel wiederzubekommen.
Der hat sein Channel nicht verkauft.
Kein M-Core-Coin, nee.
Genau.
Alles klar, Leute, wir sehen uns beim nächsten Stream.
Bis denn.
Ja, das ist nicht klar und selbst wenn ich es wüsste, kann ich jetzt da öffentlich nicht so viel dazu sagen,
weil wer weiß, ob man sonst noch den Typen in die Hände spielt oder so.
Weiß man ja nicht.
Also wie grundsätzlich sowas passieren kann, jetzt mal ohne vom M-Core zu sprechen.
Grundsätzlich ist es natürlich relativ einfach.
Du fängst hier den Keylogger ein.
Und dann ist halt die Frage, wie du das Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierungstechnisch abgesichert hast.
Übers Handy, über irgendeine zweite E-Mail.
Vielleicht hast du die Zwei-Faktor über eine App, die doch auf dem Rechner läuft.
Ja, das kann alles sein.
Aber normalerweise ist es eigentlich schon mal relativ safe, wenn du Zwei-Faktor wirklich über ein extra Gerät machst.
Naja.
100% sicher ist da natürlich nix.
Zumal man ja auch Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung meistens umgehen kann, weil es vorgenerierte Codes gibt.
Und wenn irgendwie einer einen Passwort-Manager hat und man aus dem RAM den Inhalt des Passwort-Managers abgreift oder sowas.
Alles möglich.
Aber...
Also du wirst beim M-Core wach, keine Ahnung.
Und selbst wenn ich es wüsste, willst du jetzt nichts mehr dazu erzählen, weil man weiß ja nicht, ob man den Leuten in die Hände spielt oder nicht.
Ja.
Alles klar Leute, wir sehen uns. Bis denn.
Macht's gut.
Tschüss.